I first started watching how I met your mother when my now-husband recommended it to me about a year-end today and I've washed it over and over and I think the reason why I keep going back to it is because at some point all of the characters choose themselves, whether that's Lily going and following her during this being an artist, whether it's Robin going and being a global reporter, it's something that you see everyone do and everyone struggle with.
我第一次开始看我是如何遇见你母亲的，当时我现在的丈夫在今天向我推荐了它，我一遍又一遍地把它洗了一遍又一遍，我想我之所以不断地回顾它，是因为在某个时刻，所有的角色都选择了自己，无论是莉莉在成为一名艺术家期间跟随她，还是罗宾在成为一名全球记者，这是你看到每个人都在做的事情，每个人都在挣扎。
but also something that you see their circle support them through, whether they're struggling with it or not.
而且你会看到他们的圈子支持他们度过难关，无论他们是否正在为此苦苦挣扎。
And I think that's just something that's really important to you as a young adult.
我认为这对你作为一个年轻人来说非常重要。
So I've looked to the show for a camper, but also for that support to remind me, choose yourself.
所以我在节目中寻找露营者，同时也寻求那种支持来提醒我，选择你自己。
You deserve it.
你值得拥有。
I'm alone, I'll be soon in New York City when I see you.
我孤身一人，见到你时我很快就会到纽约。
Please permit me to tell you everything in New York City.
请允许我告诉你纽约市的一切。
city.
城市。
Well, hello and welcome to how we made your mother where I, Josh Radner, talk with Craig Thomas.
好吧，你好，欢迎来到我们如何创造你的母亲，我，乔什·拉德纳，与克雷格·托马斯交谈。
Hello, Craig.
你好，克雷格。
Hey, Josh.
嘿，乔什。
We talk about a show we made together for nine years way back in the day.
我们谈论了九年前我们一起制作的一部剧。
It was called How I Met Your Mother.
它的名字叫《老爸老妈的浪漫史》。
We did 208 episodes.
我们拍了208集。
I don't even know what episode we're on right now, but we're having a great time rewatching it from our older wiser selves, unpacking what we did, what worked, what didn't work, what what we love, why people still talk about the show today, like that lovely letter we received.
我什至不知道我们现在正在看哪一集，但我们很高兴从更聪明的自己那里重温它，解开我们所做的事情，什么有效，什么无效，我们喜欢什么，为什么人们今天仍然谈论这个节目，就像我们收到的那封可爱的信一样。
How did that land on you, Craig?
克雷格，你是怎么想到这一点的？
I love it.
我喜欢它。
I love that reading of it.
我喜欢读它。
It's such a like, that wasn't about the romance, that wasn't about the sort of the narrative style that was about characters choosing themselves.
就像这样，这与浪漫无关，与角色选择自己的叙事风格无关。
That's really interesting and watching these characters have a passion and chase it.
这真的很有趣，看着这些角色充满激情并追逐它。
Some of us make sacrifices to chase their dream and it is, it's that time of life.
我们中的一些人为了追逐自己的梦想而做出牺牲，这就​​是人生的那个时刻。
the show has that energy in it.
这个节目有这样的能量。
And that's the age that we were, Josh, when we were our younger, less wise selves.
乔什，这就是我们所处的年龄，那时我们还年轻，不太聪明。
And we were chasing our dream in that exact moment.
在那一刻我们正在追逐我们的梦想。
So it's cool that I feel like that energy is imbued into the show.
所以我觉得这部剧充满了能量，这很酷。
And that makes me happy to hear this young person saying that.
这让我很高兴听到这个年轻人这么说。
That's so old when I say that.
当我这么说的时候已经很老了。
This young person.
这个年轻人。
I also, I think I said this first season, I said if the show was only being watched by single people in big cities in the Northeast, It wouldn't be recognized in Brazil and India.
我也,我想我说过这个第一季,我说如果这个节目只是东北大城市的单身人士看的话,它在巴西和印度是不会被认可的。
I absolutely.
我绝对。
So I just love Brazilian this for more years.
所以多年来我一直很喜欢巴西这个。
From the accent, I don't want to assume.
从口音来看，我不想假设。
It didn't sound like a native New York.
这听起来不像是土生土长的纽约人。
Did we know where she was from, though?
但我们知道她来自哪里吗？
I don't know.
我不知道。
We don't know.
我们不知道。
She said it.
她这么说。
Did she say it?
她说过吗？
I mean, you said the words that we've already forgotten.
我的意思是，你说了我们已经忘记的话。
Oh my god.
我的天啊。
No, she didn't say where she was from.
不，她没有说她来自哪里。
I don't think so.
我不这么认为。
No, she didn't.
不，她没有。
Okay.
好的。
This is a real test.
这是一个真正的考验。
Just rewind and find out that we're wrong.
只要倒回，就会发现我们错了。
This is how old we all are.
这就是我们大家的年龄。
But that was a great message, I love hearing that.
但这是一个很棒的信息，我喜欢听到这个。
I love hearing that specific angle, it's not what we hear every week.
我喜欢听到这个特定的角度，这不是我们每周都会听到的。
There's so many different ways that people find to fall in love with the show and enter into the lore of the show and why they keep coming back to watch it.
人们可以通过多种不同的方式爱上该剧并了解该剧的故事，以及为什么他们会不断回来观看该剧。
I mean, it's, yeah, and also you hear so much of my boyfriend introduced me to this, my wife introduced me to this, you know.
我的意思是，是的，你也经常听到我的男朋友向我介绍了这个，我的妻子向我介绍了这个，你知道。
Yeah, it's how people met their other.
是的，人们就是这样认识彼此的。
I always say a couple of times.
我总是说几次。
A lot of times.
很多次。
So watch how I met your mother together, stay together, so.
所以看看我是如何和你妈妈一起认识的，呆在一起，所以。
It seems, we go there almost every other week.
看来我们几乎每隔一周就去那里一次。
We hear a story that includes that.
我们听到过一个包含此内容的故事。
So yeah, it's amazing.
是的，这太棒了。
Well, today we're deep into season three.
好吧，今天我们已经进入第三季了。
We're on episode 11, which is called the Platinum Rule.
我们正在看第 11 集，这就是所谓的“白金规则”。
Yeah.
是的。
Alec, tell us when this episode aired.
亚历克，告诉我们这一集什么时候播出。
This aired on December 10th in the year 2007.
该节目于2007年12月10日播出。
Okay, okay.
好吧，好吧。
This episode, the Platinum Rule was written by, and I hope I'm pronouncing this correctly.
这一集，白金规则是由我写的，我希望我的发音是正确的。
Carter Bays, and Kate Thomas.
卡特·贝斯和凯特·托马斯。
That's the thomas, guys.
那是托马斯，伙计们。
It is thomas.
是托马斯.
Thank you for saying that a lot of people think it's thomas.
谢谢你说很多人都认为是托马斯。
It is not, it's thomas.
不是，是托马斯。
I'm so glad I'm finally getting that out there.
我很高兴我终于把它说出来了。
Yeah, this was written by us.
是的，这是我们写的。
This is one of the weirdest episodes, not the episode itself.
这是最奇怪的剧集之一，而不是剧集本身。
Although the episode is weird.
虽然剧情很奇怪。
And the episode is weird.
而且情节很奇怪。
The episode is super weird.
情节超级奇怪。
There's like four timelines happening.
大约有四个时间线发生。
Like it's a Russian nesting dollas of like flashbacks within flashbacks.
就像俄罗斯的嵌套娃娃一样，闪回中的闪回。
It's great, I really like that structure.
太棒了，我真的很喜欢这个结构。
It was a very strange episode in the sausage making process, and I'll explain why.
这是香肠制作过程中的一个非常奇怪的插曲，我将解释原因。
This was the exact week that the Writers Guild of America went on strike Sunday at midnight before this production week started.
就在这一周，美国作家协会在本制作周开始前的周日午夜举行了罢工。
So what would have normally happened is we would have Monday morning, done a table read, gotten notes, heard the actors perform this, rewritten it till late at night, Monday night, put out a new script that gets to the actors late at night, the care of some wonderful PAs driving around way too late because we didn't think to email in that era, we had to drive them places.
所以通常会发生的事情是，我们会在周一早上，读完表格，拿到笔记，听演员表演，重写到深夜，周一晚上，推出一个新剧本，深夜到达演员手中，一些出色的私人助理开车四处走动，太晚了，因为我们不认为在那个时代发电子邮件，我们不得不开车送他们去地方。
And then Tuesday we would have done a run through, the actors would have gotten it on their feet, they've worked on it all morning and then around lunch time or a little bit after, I just figured exactly what time run through is usually where we would see it, we would see the entire thing acted out like a play, us, the studio, the network, some of the crucial production crew, really get it in our heads what it's gonna look like and feel like go back, get notes, go back to the restroom, do another rewrite.
然后星期二我们会进行一次演练，演员们会站起来，他们整个早上都在努力，然后在午餐时间或稍后一点时间，我只是准确地计算出演练的时间通常是我们会看到它的地方，我们会看到整个事情像戏剧一样表演，我们，工作室，网络，一些关键的制作人员，真正在我们的头脑中了解它会是什么样子，感觉像回去，做笔记，回到洗手间，再做另一个重写。
None of that happened.
那一切都没有发生。
No writers were on set for it.
没有编剧在场。
There were no writers anywhere.
任何地方都没有作家。
There was no process where we got cuts and edited it because that was considered crossing the biggest line.
我们没有进行剪辑和编辑的过程，因为这被认为跨越了最大的界限。
There were no writers on set whispering all lines to you for different takes.
片场没有编剧向你耳语所有台词以供不同的拍摄。
Zero alts, no jokes, because that is a big deal when you're shooting a re-shot three days, Wednesday, Thursday, Friday, And there was always the two writers, at least on set, the writer of the episode.
零替代，没有笑话，因为当你在周三、周四、周五三天重新拍摄时，这是一件大事，而且总是有两位编剧，至少在片场，是这一集的编剧。
And usually then like someone that was paired with them, whether it was me or Carter in early seasons.
然后通常会喜欢与他们配对的人，无论是我还是早期赛季的卡特。
And then just...
然后就...
Chris Harris would have offered me the title.
克里斯·哈里斯会给我这个头衔。
Chris Harris had a senior writer on it.
克里斯·哈里斯（Chris Harris）有一位资深作家。
Yeah.
是的。
And always getting all, it's coming up with new ideas, tweaking lines, refining things.
总是得到一切，它提出新的想法，调整路线，完善东西。
None of that happened on this episode.
这一切都没有发生在这一集中。
And it is therefore the episode that sticks in my head, the least.
因此，这是最不让我印象深刻的一件事。
So when I watched this episode, I went, oh, Kristin Shaw was on our show.
所以当我看到这一集时，我就想，哦，克里斯汀·肖在我们的节目中。
Delightful.
愉快。
I like it.
我喜欢它。
She's delightful.
她很令人愉快。
I would have liked to have spent some time with her.
我很想和她一起度过一些时间。
I really would have liked to have met her.
我真的很想见到她。
I did not.
我没有。
As far as I know.
据我所知。
I don't think I did.
我不认为我做到了。
Wait, Craig.
等等，克雷格。
Help me out.
帮帮我吧。
Remind me of this.
提醒我这一点。
So was it like Sunday night like you realized the strike was authorized Sunday night?
那么，就像周日晚上一样，您意识到罢工是在周日晚上获得授权的吗？
Was there a chance maybe the strike will be averted?
罢工有可能避免吗？
No.
不。
We knew it was happening.
我们知道它正在发生。
We knew Sunday at midnight it was going to be the strike and it was down to the minute.
我们知道周日午夜将会举行罢工，而且罢工要精确到分钟。
So maybe we learned on Friday or Saturday.
所以也许我们在周五或周六学习。
So you spent that weekend remembering this episode into as good a shape as you can.
所以你在那个周末尽可能地记住了这一集。
Yes, I can remember.
是的，我记得。
To am it to Pam and say you got to shoot this.
把它告诉帕姆并说你必须拍摄这个。
From our being our Sunday night, with I think maybe me, Carter, and maybe Chris Harris, a writer's assistant, and just being like, let's just get this as good as it can be.
从我们周日晚上开始，我想也许是我、卡特，也许还有作家助理克里斯·哈里斯，我们就想，让我们尽可能地把这件事做好。
We're never gonna hear it, we're never gonna tweak it.
我们永远不会听到它，我们永远不会调整它。
Writing is rewriting, except this time, there's no rewriting.
写作就是重写，只不过这一次，没有重写。
By the time you guys were editing this, were you still on strikes?
当你们编辑这篇文章时，你们还在罢工吗？
We weren't editing it.
我们没有编辑它。
We didn't edit it, we didn't edit it.
我们没有编辑它，我们没有编辑它。
So Sue and Pam edited this?
所以苏和帕姆编辑了这个？
Sue and Pam edited it.
苏和帕姆编辑了它。
I'm trying to think if maybe one round of notes was given sort of in good faith by me and Carter, maybe that we were like, we don't feel comfortable or not supposed to.
我试着想，如果我和卡特真诚地发出了一轮笔记，也许我们会觉得不舒服或不应该这样做。
I literally don't remember, I'm not just saying that to like, to say innocent.
我真的不记得了，我这么说不仅仅是为了喜欢，为了说无辜。
Did we come in for a table read on Monday for this episode?
我们是为了周一的这一集而来参加表读的吗？
I don't even remember.
我什至不记得了。
You tell me, Brown.
你告诉我，布朗。
I don't remember.
我不记得了。
Three to two hundred eight episodes.
三到两百八集。
I don't remember.
我不记得了。
But this is a black hole for me.
但这对我来说是一个黑洞。
It's so weird.
太奇怪了。
I have no story for this guy.
我没有关于这个人的故事。
I believe you don't remember this 19 years ago.
我相信你不记得19年前的事了。
But this thing you didn't do, 19 years like that.
但这件事你没有做，就这样19年了。
I mean, of course, what I want you to say is like, I remember that week, Craig, we didn't, we were lost without all of you writers and on set.
我的意思是，当然，我想让你说的是，我记得那一周，克雷格，我们没有，没有你们所有的编剧和片场，我们迷失了方向。
You're saying you're pretty good without you guys.
你说没有你们，你也很好。
You've picked up none of my hints for you to jump in and say that and it's just fucking tumble.
你没有听懂我的任何提示，就跳出来说出那样的话，结果就是他妈的翻滚。
But I don't remember like, I don't remember a table read where it was like us, Michael Shea, Pam, and like Alex and just some executives.
但我不记得，我不记得有一张桌子上写着我们、迈克尔·谢伊、帕姆、亚历克斯和一些高管。
You wouldn't have done it.
你不会这么做的。
I think we didn't do a table read.
我想我们没有读表。
You would have just started getting it on its feet.
你可能刚刚开始站起来。
You would have started getting it on its feet on the stage, on the sets, and walking through it.
你会开始让它在舞台上、在片场上站稳脚跟，并在其中行走。
You probably did two days of that instead of one day of that.
你可能做了两天而不是一天。
And that was it.
就是这样。
You probably sat in the main set.
您可能坐在主组中。
You probably sat in Ted's living room and read it through just to read it, but not cause anyone was gonna rewrite it or change a word, not a word changed.
你可能坐在特德的客厅里通读它只是为了读它，但并不是因为有人会重写它或改变一个词，而不是一个词被改变。
So this was the only episode we did when you guys were on strike.
所以这是我们在你们罢工时制作的唯一一集。
Yes, this one just goes over.
是的，这个就过去了。
It was just cause you had it like queued up ready to go that we were allowed to do it.
正是因为您已经排队准备出发，所以我们才被允许这样做。
We had it close enough.
我们已经足够接近了。
Just to explain to people, so like we, the actors are in the screen actors guild.
只是为了向人们解释一下，所以像我们一样，演员也是演员协会的成员。
Carter and Craig were in the writers guild, the WGA.
卡特和克雷格是作家协会 WGA 的成员。
They're totally different unions.
他们是完全不同的工会。
which means that the Screen Actors Guild was not on strike.
这意味着美国演员工会没有罢工。
The Directors Guild, Pam, and Michael Shea, not on strike.
导演协会、帕姆和迈克尔·谢没有罢工。
The Heron Makeup and all the crew, their unions, not on strike.
Heron Makeup 和所有船员，他们的工会，没有罢工。
The only union that was on strike was the WGA.
唯一举行罢工的工会是 WGA。
So the writers had to go home.
于是编剧们只好回家了。
The writers deal was up, this was 2007, it had been many years since the last strike, which I think had been the late 80s before that.
编剧合同到期了，那是 2007 年，距离上次罢工已经很多年了，我想在那之前是 80 年代末。
Alec, maybe you can double check me on that.
亚历克，也许你可以再检查一下我。
But it's been a long time.
但已经过去很长时间了。
I remember watching David Letterman and the late 80s and they're like, we have no writers.
我记得看过大卫·莱特曼和 80 年代末的电影，他们说，我们没有作家。
And they were just like filling time with weird shit.
他们就像用奇怪的东西来打发时间一样。
And I wrote you this little ditty to sing to you in New York City.
我给你写了这首小曲，是为了在纽约唱给你听。
We'll be right back.
我们马上回来。
And now, back to the show.
现在，回到节目。
Do you remember what the central issue was?
你还记得中心问题是什么吗？
Was this DVD residuals?
这是DVD残留吗？
Was this streaming that started to be an issue?
这个流媒体开始成为一个问题吗？
Yeah, so 2007, just not streaming.
是的，2007 年，只是没有流媒体。
because it was just starting.
因为一切才刚刚开始。
But yeah, it was the beginning, it was the seeds of all of that.
但是，是的，这是开始，是所有这一切的种子。
Of, all right, our written content is creeping off of CBS.
好吧，我们的书面内容正在从哥伦比亚广播公司（CBS）上悄悄流出。
It's creeping off of network television and cable television.
它正在从网络电视和有线电视中悄然消失。
It's creeping onto DVDs.
它正在悄然出现在 DVD 上。
More DVDs are still a very big deal then.
那时，更多 DVD 仍然是一件大事。
And writers were getting peanuts of that.
作家们从中获益匪浅。
And studios were making a lot of money on that.
工作室靠此赚了很多钱。
The content was starting to be in places like you could buy the show on iTunes and watch it.
内容开始出现在你可以在 iTunes 上购买节目并观看的地方。
And everyone new streaming was coming.
每个新的流媒体都即将到来。
I don't know exactly where it would have been at this moment in 2007.
我不知道 2007 年的此时此刻它会在哪里。
I'm not, maybe you can double check me on that too.
我不是，也许你也可以仔细检查一下我。
I like, I don't think there was their digital like Netflix that wasn't just like DVDs and pouches in 2007.
我喜欢，我不认为 2007 年他们的数字产品像 Netflix 那样不仅仅是 DVD 和小袋。
I don't think so.
我不这么认为。
So a year or two before that started, right?
那么开始前一两年，对吧？
Do you know what's a crazy thing?
你知道什么是疯狂的事情吗？
Like basically all these strikes have to happen when new technology comes on.
基本上所有这些罢工都必须在新技术出现时发生。
Yes, so it was that theme.
是的，这就是那个主题。
It was that theme.
就是那个主题。
It was a very early moment of that theme.
这是该主题的早期阶段。
And the big question was the same, which is, wait a second, there's all these rules for our written work, your active work, Pam's directed work, to be used in this main way it's used.
最大的问题是相同的，那就是，等一下，我们的书面作品、你的主动作品、帕姆的指导作品都有所有这些规则，要以这种主要方式使用。
Now that's changing, you're gonna use it all these other ways.
现在情况正在改变，您将通过其他方式使用它。
Pay us very, very little for that.
为此付给我们的钱非常非常少。
And you guys, the studios and the big companies are still gonna make a lot of money on it.
你们、工作室和大公司仍然会从中赚很多钱。
Hey, we have a problem, we're the ones creating this material that you're gonna make a lot of money on and we have no fair equation for compensation for that.
嘿，我们有一个问题，我们是创造这种材料的人，你会从中赚很多钱，但我们没有公平的补偿方程式。
And it's really exactly the same.
而且真的一模一样。
There has been another writer's guild strike since then a couple of years ago that is very much about all of these issues, but now through the lens of streaming and the changing of the industry and the shrinking of the industry, the shrinking of writer's rooms, the shrinking of having writers on set and in production and all these other issues that are related to the issues in 2007.
几年前，又发生了一次编剧工会罢工，主要涉及所有这些问题，但现在通过流媒体和行业的变化以及行业的萎缩、编剧室的缩小、编剧在片场和制作中的缩减以及所有其他与 2007 年的问题相关的问题来看。
And so what happened was we knew it was coming.
所以发生的事情是我们知道它即将到来。
We were hoping it would be averted.
我们希望它能够被避免。
It wasn't, we hit send around 11.59 on Sunday night.
事实并非如此，我们在周日晚上 11.59 左右发送了邮件。
And we said, I hope this goes well.
我们说，我希望一切顺利。
And then we started picketing around your own studio.
然后我们开始在你自己的工作室周围设置纠察线。
The studio lot while you shot the episode.
拍摄这一集时的工作室。
I think it's during lunch.
我想是在午餐时间。
We would come out and pick it with you.
我们会出来和你一起挑选。
Like, I know we joined the picket line a little bit.
就像，我知道我们加入了一点纠察线。
You would join us.
你会加入我们。
I was most, the funny thing is, because my son was born right between your two and three.
有趣的是，我是最重要的，因为我的儿子出生在你两岁和三岁之间。
And so I was, for me, and it was many months, it was like, maybe you can double check me on this too, Alec, you're my fact-decker today.
对我来说，这已经是好几个月了，也许你也可以再仔细检查一下我，亚历克，你今天是我的事实证明者。
I think that strike was about three and a half months.
我认为那次罢工持续了大约三个半月。
I think it was something like that.
我认为是这样的。
I could be wrong, but it was three months, I actually got all this time with my six month old boy, I wouldn't have, and my wife who was exhausted by that point was like, you know what you can do when you're picketing?
我可能是错的，但那是三个月，我实际上和我六个月大的儿子在一起，我不会有这么多时间，我的妻子当时已经筋疲力尽了，她说，你知道当你纠察时你能做什么吗？
push a stroller.
推婴儿车。
So I would go to the Elliott walk the picket line with you.
所以我会和你一起去埃利奥特走纠察线。
Oh yeah, all of it's a lot.
哦，是的，所有这些都很多。
And I would go, I lived walking distance in Culver City from the Sony lot.
我会去，我住在卡尔弗城，距离索尼工厂步行即可到达。
And I could see the Sony lot.
我还可以看到索尼的展位。
If I walked out my front door and just peek my head, I could see the Sony lot two blocks away.
如果我走出前门，只要抬起头，我就能看到两个街区外的索尼工厂。
So I'd walk over there with Elliott and just push him around, maybe had a sign and it was sort of just like fishing around and pick it.
所以我会和埃利奥特一起走到那里，把他推来推去，也许有一个标志，这有点像四处钓鱼并挑选它。
But a lot of the rest of the Hemium writers mostly went to where we were.
但其他许多 Hemium 作家大多都去了我们所在的地方。
Elliot has like a weird taste for social justice.
艾略特对社会正义有一种奇怪的品味。
He doesn't know why.
他不知道为什么。
I think he does.
我认为他确实如此。
Yeah.
是的。
He's just like in his bloodstream.
他就像在他的血液里一样。
Let me just throw out the fact here.
让我在这里抛出一个事实。
So yeah, the one before that was 1988 and that went for 22 weeks.
是的，之前的那次是 1988 年，持续了 22 周。
And yeah, they're saying that it was about cable TV and VHS and it was the new technology of the day.
是的，他们说这是关于有线电视和 VHS 的，这是当时的新技术。
And this one I see is being listed as having lasted in 2007 for a hundred days.
我看到的这个在2007年被列为持续了一百天。
So yeah, just over three months also.
是的，也只有三个多月了。
Wow.
哇。
It was long.
时间很长。
And it was so weird, so there was a huge gap between this episode and the next episode, which is called No Tomorrow of several months, between those two airing.
这太奇怪了，所以这一集和下一集之间存在巨大的差距，这集被称为几个月后的《没有明天》，两次播出之间。
And I remember it just being so scary because our show was getting a lot of momentum in year three.
我记得这太可怕了，因为我们的节目在第三年势头强劲。
We weren't a big hit yet, but we were in year three.
我们还没有大受欢迎，但我们已经进入了第三年。
We'd found our footing.
我们找到了立足点。
I felt, I mean, I don't know how you feel, Josh.
我觉得，我是说，我不知道你的感受，乔什。
I feel like creatively to this point, we've just done this rewatch, we're 11 episodes in.
我觉得到目前为止，我们已经重看了一遍，已经有 11 集了，很有创意。
I feel like the season's great.
我感觉这个赛季很棒。
I don't think things are going really well.
我认为事情进展得不太顺利。
And I was fucking terrified.
我他妈的害怕极了。
We're hitting this brick wall.
我们正在碰壁。
We're fighting against the corporate overlords who we're asking for money, millions of dollars to make this show and to keep our show on the air.
我们正在与企业霸主作斗争，我们向他们要钱，数百万美元来制作这个节目并让我们的节目继续播出。
What if during this strike, if it goes on, non-non, shows start getting canceled and cut?
如果在这次罢工期间，如果继续下去，演出开始被取消和削减怎么办？
And it's like, okay, you guys want more money and you're robbing us of product?
就好像，好吧，你们想要更多的钱，却抢走了我们的产品？
Fuck you, we're gonna cancel these 12 shows and we're one of them.
操你妈的，我们要取消这 12 场演出，而我们就是其中之一。
It was a very scary time.
那是一段非常可怕的时光。
You know, so much has to go right for a show to run nine years.
你知道，一部剧要连续播出九年，需要做很多事情。
Like so much has to go right.
就像很多事情都必须走对路一样。
How many bullets do you have to die?
你得死多少子弹？
You don't want to remind me of like, you look at a career like LeBron James or Michael Jordan, like they're, they had that career, but for they, they didn't get injured.
你不想提醒我，你看看勒布朗·詹姆斯或迈克尔·乔丹这样的职业生涯，就像他们一样，他们有那样的职业生涯，但对他们来说，他们没有受伤。
Like they didn't have, they didn't come down on their ankle.
就像他们没有那样，他们没有摔倒脚踝。
One play could have changed those historic careers, you know?
一场比赛可能会改变那些历史性的职业生涯，你知道吗？
Yeah.
是的。
I wanted to say one thing about these strikes that come up, and I hope this isn't two in the weeds for people, you know, They just, you know, because this really is about how the show was made and what was going on.
关于这些出现的罢工，我想说一件事，我希望这对人们来说不是两件事，你知道，他们只是，你知道，因为这确实是关于节目的制作方式和正在发生的事情。
And this is like, this is actually like a really big story in terms of this episode and how it was made and all this stuff.
这就像，就这一集及其制作方式和所有这些内容而言，这实际上是一个非常大的故事。
So I'm glad we're talking about this.
所以我很高兴我们正在谈论这个。
I hope this is interesting people.
我希望这是有趣的人。
It's very interesting to me.
这对我来说很有趣。
But my brother-in-law Gideon told me, we were having a talk about AI.
但我的姐夫吉迪恩告诉我，我们正在谈论人工智能。
And he said, and I think this is historically true, that any time there's a new communication medium, it introduced, millions of people die.
他说，我认为这在历史上是正确的，只要有一种新的通讯媒介出现，就会有数百万人死亡。
Like there's millions of like wars and displacement, like the printing press, like there were massive wars in Asia, massive, you know, disruptions throughout Europe.
就像有数以百万计的战争和流离失所，就像印刷机，就像亚洲发生了大规模战争，你知道，整个欧洲都发生了大规模的破坏。
Like these new technologies are not, they bring a host of anxiety to humanity, you know?
就像这些新技术一样，它们给人类带来了许多焦虑，你知道吗？
And so I think like when people were taking to the picket line, Like, it's really hard for people to understand how emotional making stuff is, you know?
所以我认为当人们走上纠察线时，人们真的很难理解制作东西是多么情绪化，你知道吗？
And how, you know, you guys weren't writing autobiography, but you were certainly like, you know, Carter was the Ted and you were the Marshall and Lily with Rebecca, like your whole beating heart.
你们知道，你们并不是在写自传，但你们肯定会说，卡特就是泰德，而你们和丽贝卡就是马歇尔和莉莉，就像你们整个跳动的心一样。
And I would say out of most shows I know, you guys put your whole beating heart into this show.
我想说的是，在我知道的大多数节目中，你们把全部的心都投入到了这个节目中。
Yeah.
是的。
But also like, the only way to get things done through solidarity and through, you know, communal action.
但也就像，通过团结和通过集体行动来完成任务的唯一方法。
Yes.
是的。
So you guys had to, you know, you're, and no one on set.
所以你们必须这样做，你知道，你们，而且片场没有人。
There's not a single Susie Greenberg pam.
没有一个苏西·格林伯格帕姆。
No one thought you should object to your union's action.
没有人认为你应该反对工会的行动。
Yeah, you guys know everyone's supportive.
是的，你们知道每个人都支持。
Everyone's supportive.
大家都很支持。
You shot this one episode, which you had to do.
你拍摄了这一集，这是你必须做的。
You're contractually obligated to do it.
根据合同规定，您有义务这样做。
And we had provided the script.
我们已经提供了剧本。
Yeah.
是的。
And then that was it.
然后就这样了。
Then you guys were done till we were back.
然后你们就完成了，直到我们回来。
and the writers guilds did make gains in these issues of compensation and residuals and new rules.
而作家协会在赔偿、剩余和新规则等问题上也确实有所收获。
The beginning of trying to find a sort of a structure and the you know a proper and fair compensation system for these new technologies.
开始尝试寻找一种结构，并且您知道这些新技术的适当且公平的补偿系统。
It's it's all you make these incremental gains not everything was solved There was another strike a few years ago because if it wasn't all solved and they'll they'll this will keep happening but you have to do it sometimes.
这就是你取得这些增量收益的全部，并不是所有问题都得到了解决几年前又发生了一次罢工，因为如果问题没有全部解决，他们会继续发生这种情况，但有时你必须这样做。
There's no other way to stick up for the creative side of this equation that tells the stories.
没有其他方法可以坚持这个讲述故事的等式的创造性方面。
And you know, a lot of people don't understand, like a lot of people I think just think, in some weird part of their brain, they're like, well, Neil and Josh and Ali and Kobe and Jason wrote this show.
你知道，很多人不明白，就像很多人我想的那样，在他们大脑的某个奇怪的部分，他们就像，嗯，尼尔、乔什、阿里、科比和杰森写了这个节目。
Right, they say all those words.
是的，他们说了所有这些话。
They say all those words.
他们说了所有这些话。
They must have just been really funny people that these cameras are following them around.
他们一定是非常有趣的人，这些摄像机一直跟踪着他们。
The scripts we received, and you know this, if you know how many, they're so clever, so tightly structured, so brilliant.
我们收到的剧本，你知道这一点，如果你知道有多少，它们是如此聪明，结构如此紧密，如此出色。
And what people don't understand, like if AI starts writing all your TV shows, you're not gonna like TV that much.
人们不明白的是，比如如果人工智能开始编写你所有的电视节目，你就不会那么喜欢电视了。
Like it's not, it's going to be a simulacrum of the thing you like, and you will smell it in authenticity, and you will not like it.
就像不是一样，它将成为你喜欢的东西的幻影，你会真实地闻到它的味道，但你不会喜欢它。
The things you love the best are made by humans.
你最喜欢的东西是人类创造的。
Yes.
是的。
And I'm very team human, and I really, like I have a theory, I don't know if this is true, but I suspect it's true.
我是一个很有团队精神的人，我真的，就像我有一个理论，我不知道这是否属实，但我怀疑这是真的。
I think that the theater is gonna have some big renaissance in the age of reality.
我认为剧院在现实时代将会有一些大的复兴。
I totally agree.
我完全同意。
I think sporting events too are gonna be.
我认为体育赛事也会如此。
And analog things in person thing.
并模拟人的事物。
Because you're gonna be like, I wanna be in a room with a verified human.
因为你会说，我想和一个经过验证的人待在一个房间里。
I wanna know that I'm watching a human being.
我想知道我正在观察一个人。
I wanna see factor authentication of humanity.
我想看到人性的因素认证。
Yes.
是的。
And I think sitting elbow to elbow with actual human beings in a room, sharing stories, like it's gonna get back to like, I heard this thing that said, all revolutions in art are a return to realism.
我认为与真实的人类坐在一个房间里，分享故事，就像它会回到喜欢的那样，我听到这句话说，所有艺术革命都是对现实主义的回归。
Like it's always like coming back to first principles, you know?
就像总是回到第一原则一样，你知道吗？
And I just think there's something about the age we're in that there's gonna be such a hunger for like analog gatherings and spaces.
我只是认为我们所处的时代会如此渴望类似的聚会和空间。
And I know I hunger for them.
我知道我渴望它们。
I'm like, I'm the same, I agree completely.
我想，我也是一样，我完全同意。
When I go out to dinner without my phone and I'm just like, oh my God, I feel better.
当我出去吃饭时不带手机时，我就想，天哪，我感觉好多了。
Yeah.
是的。
You know, it's hard to leave initially, but then you just feel a lot better.
你知道，一开始离开很难，但后来你感觉好多了。
You know, you mentioned that it was like Russian nesting dolls.
你知道，你提到它就像俄罗斯套娃。
I actually looked up, is it Matrioshka or something like that?
我真的抬起头来，是俄罗斯套娃还是类似的东西？
Yeah, Matrioshka, I think I did not say it right, but that is the word for it, yeah.
是的，Matrioshka，我想我说得不对，但就是这个词，是的。
But it really does, this episode really does.
但确实如此，这一集确实如此。
Our Maritoshka, made me Maritoshka, Maritoshka, yeah, yeah.
我们的玛丽托什卡，让我成为玛丽托什卡，玛丽托什卡，是的，是的。
Alec, I've left this episode before because we so often use a narrative, sort of metaphorical version of that.
亚历克，我之前已经离开了这一集，因为我们经常使用叙述性的隐喻版本。
I've thought about that word.
我想过这个词。
That's what this one is.
这就是这个。
It's, yeah, and I really liked the structure of it.
是的，我真的很喜欢它的结构。
I watched this one, it was like, every other episode of Amiem, I watched 20 cuts of it.
我看了这一集，就像《Amiem》的每一集一样，我看了 20 个剪辑。
You know, whittling it down from starting six minutes to long, seven minutes to long, you whittle it down and down and you perfect it, you tighten it up a lot.
你知道，从开始的六分钟到长，到七分钟到长，你不断地削减它，你完善它，你把它收紧很多。
This one, I was like, oh, right, I saw this when it aired, you know?
这个，我当时想，哦，对了，我在播出时看到了这个，你知道吗？
I think when you're, I know this from editing two movies that I wrote and directed, when you're in the editing room, it's in your bloodstream.
我想当你在剪辑室时，我从剪辑我自编自导的两部电影中知道这一点，它就在你的血液中。
Like you are, you're saying like, don't cut that on the blink.
就像你一样，你说的是，不要眨眼就剪掉它。
Like you do stuff.
就像你做事一样。
You're fucking, you're talking three frames off of there.
你他妈的，你说的已经是三帧了。
Let's go.
我们走吧。
Three frames sooner.
快了三帧。
Oh, it's so much better.
哦，好多了。
And it's funnier.
而且更有趣。
It is better.
更好了。
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
是啊，是啊，是啊。
It's a weird, little and like mystical science.
这是一门奇怪的、小而神秘的科学。
I watched this episode and I think to myself, there could have been a few more joke.
我看了这一集，我心里想，可能还有更多的笑话。
You know, I could, I watched it, I'm like, I see the part where we were 80% there.
你知道，我可以，我看了它，我想，我看到了我们 80% 的部分。
Or you see the part.
或者你看到了这个部分。
And it's a really good 80%.
这是一个非常好的 80%。
You see the part where having writers on set bumps it up into the different level.
你会看到编剧在片场将其提升到不同水平的部分。
You just would have found stuff.
你就会找到东西。
It's a little, it's a great structure.
虽然很小，但结构很棒。
You guys were great.
你们太棒了。
I think you guys knew you had to bring it in the absence of us refining it.
我想你们知道在我们没有完善它的情况下你们必须把它带来。
I thought that you guys were, I really was grateful to you.
我以为你们是，我真的很感激你们。
I was like, you guys made this episode better than it would have been.
我当时想，你们让这一集变得比原来更好。
I would say structurally, it's one of the more inventive episodes of how I made a mother joke-wise, it's not as- It's light, it's a little slow at times, it's a little joke-light, and it's a little like, you can see the form in the structure, and it's missing the couple of extra steps where we would have just found those little twists.
我想说，从结构上来说，这是我如何制作一个母亲笑话方面更具创造性的剧集之一，它不是那么-它很轻，有时有点慢，有点笑话轻，它有点像，你可以在结构中看到形式，它缺少我们刚刚发现那些小曲折的几个额外步骤。
I normally do this earlier, but tell us just a little bit, like tell us what this episode is.
我通常会提前这样做，但只告诉我们一点，比如告诉我们这一集是什么。
Yeah, no, no, no, about 22 minutes in, it seems like a good moment to thesis statement.
是的，不，不，不，大约 22 分钟后，这似乎是论文陈述的好时机。
So that's where the thesis statement goes in the paper, right?
这就是论文中的论文陈述的位置，对吗？
We're, it's the Russian nesting doll version of, uh, of this podcast.
我们是，这是这个播客的俄罗斯嵌套娃娃版本。
So it is, this episode is the platinum rule, which is they essentially don't shit where you eat, don't, uh, don't screw up, uh, your little world by hooking up with someone that is right there in your world.
是的，这一集是白金规则，这就是他们基本上不会在你吃饭的地方拉屎，不要，呃，不要通过与你世界中的某个人勾搭来搞砸，呃，你的小世界。
You need some level of distance because it will always end in calamity.
你需要一定程度的距离，因为它总会以灾难告终。
And there's the present day conundrum of Ted considering getting involved with his doctor.
泰德目前面临着一个难题，他正在考虑与他的医生联系。
Ted Ted's thing is that it's not quite, it's not really someone that involved with it.
特德·特德的问题在于，事情并不完全是这样，他并不是真正参与其中的人。
They're like, no, no, this counts.
他们说，不，不，这很重要。
And it that sparks this flashback within a flashback with a flashback episode where you see everyone in the gang's version of having broken the platinum rule and paid some kind of a consequence.
它引发了闪回中的闪回和闪回情节，你会看到该帮派版本中的每个人都打破了白金规则并付出了某种后果。
Right.
正确的。
And he hooks up with the Monday of the waitress, Marshall and Lily get way too close with the new couple across the hall way too quickly, way too quickly.
他和女服务员的星期一勾搭上了，马歇尔和莉莉与穿过走廊的新婚夫妇走得太近了，太快了，太快了。
Robin, the worst one of all, the most timeless version of breaking the platinum rule, sleeping with the weatherman, sports guy, cooking up with your coworker who you are just tethered to every day.
罗宾，最糟糕的一个，打破白金规则的最永恒的版本，与天气预报员、运动员一起睡觉，与每天与你联系在一起的同事一起做饭。
She, she, I would say hers is the quintessential iteration of this, but Barney, I love the Barney one of whether I was like, don't kill the bar.
她，她，我想说她的就是这个的典型迭代，但是巴尼，我喜欢巴尼之一，不管我是不是喜欢，不要杀死酒吧。
Don't kill the bar.
别杀了酒吧。
We love this bar.
我们喜欢这个酒吧。
It's a little bit of a big Lebowski.
这是一个有点大的勒博斯基。
Don't kill the of our dude.
别杀了我们的家伙。
There's like a little bit big Lebasky rhythm in there.
里面有一点大的勒巴斯基节奏。
But it's, it's, it's basically don't, don't poison the well.
但它是，它是，它基本上不要，不要在井里投毒。
You know, you have to look, please look elsewhere.
你知道，你必须看看，请看看别处。
So it's, it's an exploration of something very real.
所以，这是对非常真实的事物的探索。
And each, within each flashback, each, for each set of people are telling, telling the next person not to make the mistake that they made.
在每个闪回中，每一组人都在讲述，告诉下一个人不要犯他们所犯的错误。
And then you back it up and you see the other person made the mistake before that.
然后你备份它，你会发现其他人之前就犯了错误。
And it has this implication that this, this is an endless cycle of making this mistake that will continue for infinity.
它有这样的含义，这是一个犯这个错误的无休止的循环，将无限地持续下去。
Well, it makes, it's actually like a very human conundrum.
嗯，这实际上就像一个非常人性化的难题。
I think the issue that you guys are exploring is like very timeless because isn't there, there's some weird statistic about, and it's changing now, I think, with online, but like the number of spouses that meet at work is pretty high.
我认为你们正在探索的问题是非常永恒的，因为不存在，有一些奇怪的统计数据，而且现在它正在改变，我认为，随着在线，但就像在工作中见面的配偶数量相当高。
Yeah, you know.
是的，你知道。
Yeah, now it works out.
是的，现在成功了。
It works out a great deal of the time.
很多时候它都很有效。
Yeah, but when it doesn't.
是的，但是当没有的时候。
But when it doesn't.
但当它没有的时候。
But when it doesn't, it's a disaster.
但如果不这样做，那就是一场灾难。
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
是啊，是啊，是啊，是啊。
but it's also there's a feeling of, well, I'm here and you're here.
但也有一种感觉，嗯，我在这里，你也在这里。
Yeah.
是的。
There's a kind of, even like, you're just across the hall.
有一种，甚至就像，你就在大厅对面。
Is this it?
是这个吗？
Is it happening right now?
现在正在发生吗？
This is my big proposal to you.
这是我给你的一个重大建议。
No way, like, they're just, like the neighbors.
不可能，他们只是，就像邻居一样。
They're just across the hall, like, what a dream to have your best couple friends live across the hall from you.
他们就在大厅对面，就像，让你最好的情侣朋友住在你对面的大厅真是一个梦想。
Oh my God, Marshall and Lily's true dream.
天啊，马歇尔和莉莉的真正梦想。
That's a couple friends across the hall.
那是大厅对面的一对朋友。
They're surrounded by single people in their life.
他们的生活中被单身人士包围。
Yeah.
是的。
That's one of Marshall and Lily's big series arcs.
这是马歇尔和莉莉的大系列故事之一。
is just we want couple friends.
只是我们想要情侣朋友。
That's the whole front porch test thing.
这就是整个前廊测试的事情。
We just want to grow old with another couple.
我们只是想和另一对夫妇一起变老。
And there's so frickin thirsty for that.
人们对此非常渴望。
You know what it did occur to me during this episode as I was watching it?
你知道我在观看这一集时发生了什么吗？
I was like, how did Ted, narrator Ted, tell this story to his kids?
我当时想，特德，叙述者特德，是如何向他的孩子们讲述这个故事的？
Cause I understand how we're being told this story by Carter, Craig, and Pam.
因为我理解卡特、克雷格和帕姆是如何向我们讲述这个故事的。
But like at some point his kids are like, wait, what?
但就像在某个时候，他的孩子们会说，等等，什么？
Like who are you talking?
就像你在说谁？
What timeline are we in here?
我们现在处于什么时间线？
Where are we right now?
我们现在在哪里？
You know what I'm saying?
你知道我在说什么吗？
Yes, yes, it's a very, it would be a really hard story to tell verbally.
是的，是的，这是一个非常非常难以用语言讲述的故事。
Yes, that's what I'm saying.
是的，我就是这么说的。
That's what I'm saying.
这就是我所说的。
It's so dependent on the, you know, the quits that we do.
这非常依赖于我们所做的戒烟。
Yeah, I don't know that it can be done.
是的，我不知道这可以做到。
Yeah.
是的。
It's a hard episode to ditch.
这是一个很难放弃的情节。
I do, I remember, there was a part of me that was like, a little bit, like, cause you said, we talked that that Pulp Fiction was such a big influence on you guys, like the non-linear narrative, and we also shout out Quentin Tarantino.
我确实，我记得，我内心深处有一点点，因为你说，我们谈到《低俗小说》对你们影响很大，比如非线性叙事，我们也大声疾呼昆汀·塔伦蒂诺。
The rest of our dogs does that really well.
我们其他的狗在这方面做得很好。
Huge, huge, him, fan, if Quentin Tarantino is listening to most of them on the show, we'd love to have you.
巨大的，巨大的，他的粉丝，如果昆汀·塔伦蒂诺在节目中听了他们中的大多数，我们很乐意邀请​​你。
Please come on, Quentin.
请来吧，昆汀。
He said such nice things so many times in public and in the press.
他在公开场合和媒体上多次说过这样的好话。
Approach me at a party.
在聚会上接近我。
Approach you at a party.
在聚会上接近你。
Yeah.
是的。
Him and the super fan, Quentin Tarantino, please come.
他和他的超级粉丝昆汀·塔伦蒂诺请来。
But he was reciprocal because you guys loved his story structure and his movies.
但他是互惠的，因为你们喜欢他的故事结构和他的电影。
But I remember when you're being told a story that is that non-linear, where the puzzle pieces kind of get thrown in the air.
但我记得当你被告知一个非线性的故事时，拼图碎片会被抛到空中。
You really have to trust the vision behind it and the people making it.
你真的必须相信它背后的愿景和创造它的人们。
I remember, I remember very strongly, because I had to just fuss with my hair for like a day.
我记得，我记得非常清楚，因为我不得不花一天的时间来整理我的头发。
I have the episode.
我有情节。
Yeah.
是的。
So I remember that very strongly.
所以我记得很清楚。
But I remember in the flashbacks, I remember being like, I'm not quite sure what timeline we're in.
但我记得在闪回中，我记得我不太确定我们处于什么时间线。
I'm just going to, I know the story in this moment, I'm going to trust that in this is all going to, they're going to put this together and it's going to make sense.
我只是要，我知道这一刻的故事，我相信这一切都会发生，他们会将这些放在一起，并且它会有意义。
I'm going to try to set the writers are going to get in the edit room.
我将尝试让编剧进入编辑室。
Wait, no, they're waiting.
等等，不，他们在等。
I'm going to trust that the writers who were just over there.
我会相信那边的作家们。
Wait, where are they?
等等，他们在哪儿？
They're yelling things through the window with picket signs.
他们拿着纠察牌隔着窗户大喊大叫。
They're yelling over the fence to us.
他们隔着栅栏向我们大喊大叫。
What's happening?
发生什么事了？
It was just probably a very not great episode to not have writers there for it because we were Really complicated.
如果没有编剧，这可能是一个非常不精彩的插曲，因为我们真的很复杂。
Yeah blueprint like good luck But if you had to hand if you had to hand and your beloved baby show over to anyone.
是的，蓝图就像祝你好运，但如果你必须交出，如果你必须交出，你心爱的宝宝就会展示给任何人。
It's like Pam, take it.
就像帕姆，接受它。
At that point, she had directed, she was part of the beating heart of the show.
在她导演的那一刻，她成为了这部剧的核心部分。
She directed every episode, more or less, Rob had done a couple, but yeah, and you guys, thank God it happened in year three, because you guys were so gelled, we keep talking about this season, everyone is just really clicking, really firing on all cylinders.
她导演了每一集，或多或少，罗布做了几集，但是，是的，你们，感谢上帝，这发生在第三年，因为你们是如此团结，我们一直在谈论这个赛季，每个人都非常认真，真的在全力以赴。
We had a great crew, people had been there the whole time, Pam and director in almost every episode.
我们有一个很棒的工作人员，人们一直都在那里，帕姆和导演几乎每一集都在那里。
It was, we were uniquely suited for this episode to work, but I still see what, you know, I see all the, I see the parts that could have been better.
是的，我们非常适合这一集的工作，但我仍然看到了什么，你知道，我看到了所有，我看到了可以做得更好的部分。
But what do you, what do you have other memories of like the feeling of it, the idea that there's just no writers, there's no one on set, there's no one, there's no demo read, there's no, it must have been a weird, it must have been a strange feeling.
但是你呢，你还有什么其他记忆，比如那种感觉，没有编剧，没有人在片场，没有人，没有演示，没有，这一定是一种奇怪的感觉，一定是一种奇怪的感觉。
I mean, you saw us, you knew we were right outside picketing, we're very texting, we're probably calling you guys, But it was, what a strange week for the actors and for that said, and then to shut down for three months at the end of that week.
我的意思是，你看到了我们，你知道我们就在纠察队外面，我们经常发短信，我们可能会给你们打电话，但这对演员来说是多么奇怪的一周，就这一点而言，然后在那周结束时关闭了三个月。
I mean, it's already being, it's already weird being on a television show.
我的意思是，它已经存在了，出现在电视节目中已经很奇怪了。
Even with the writers there.
即使那里有作家。
Every day is weird, every day is like, this isn't like Ohio, but yeah, I mean, I think it was like, I think when you're making a show, when you're making 22 to 24 episodes a year, you don't, I don't know, you don't, It doesn't serve you to do a lot of like hmm like like you just do you get enough flow state you get enough flow state you're just doing the next one you try to rest when you're not there you're juggling a lot of different things that are going on yeah but I don't I mean to be fascinating like I don't know if we're gonna talk to it'd be weird like if we have other cast members on we're like let's talk about the platinum rule like I don't I don't think a lot of people, I don't know what other people would remember about it.
每一天都很奇怪，每一天都像，这不像俄亥俄州，但是，是的，我的意思是，我认为这就像，我认为当你制作一个节目时，当你每年制作 22 到 24 集时，你不，我不知道，你不，做很多像嗯，就像你只是做你得到足够的心流状态你得到足够的心流状态你只是在做下一个你试图休息的时候不在那里，你正在处理很多正在发生的不同事情，是的，但我不是，我的意思是变得很有趣，就像我不知道我们是否要谈论它会很奇怪，就像我们有其他演员一样，我们就像让我们谈论白金规则，就像我不认为很多人一样，我不知道其他人会记得它。
But I totally forgotten until you said that this was the strike-up.
但我完全忘记了，直到你说这是罢工。
Well, this episode, I watched this as if for the first time last night.
嗯，这一集，我昨晚好像第一次看。
I really was like, I forgot.
我真的是，我忘记了。
Like, Kristin Schall is just a good example or is like, I forgot she was on the show.
就像，克里斯汀·夏尔只是一个很好的例子，或者就像，我忘了她在节目中。
And I really like her.
我真的很喜欢她。
This was a black hole.
这是一个黑洞。
This was really, so preoccupied.
这实在是太着急了。
I remember the feeling of being in the season three writer's offices and just like drinking a scotch and proofing the script for one last time with Carter and I think Chris Harris and just going like, God, what is this going to be?
我记得在第三季编剧办公室的感觉，就像喝了一杯苏格兰威士忌，最后一次与卡特一起校对剧本，我想克里斯·哈里斯就会想，上帝，这会是什么？
Is this going to be a one week strike?
这将是为期一周的罢工吗？
Is this going to be a fucking six month strike when are we going to make, is this show going to get canceled?
这会是一场他妈的为期六个月的罢工吗？我们什么时候才能制作，这个节目会被取消吗？
Are we going to do this again?
我们还要再做一次吗？
And you just, but all you could do, like you said, is just put your head down, make the script as good as you can, pencils down at midnight.
而你，但你所能做的，就像你说的，只是低下头，尽你所能地把剧本写好，在午夜用铅笔写下来。
Yeah.
是的。
That's the contract.
这就是合同。
That's the, that's the, you know, that's the, the broke code of writers was like, actually stop.
这就是，那是，你知道，那是，作家的破坏代码就像，实际上停止了。
Don't keep going, don't secretly go around, don't sneak in and don't be emailing jokes and alts and don't be like really try to, try to starve these corporations of our material to prove to them how valuable our material is in this changing industry in which we're being undercompensated and where we're being devalued and we're being taken for granted.
不要继续前进，不要偷偷摸摸，不要偷偷溜进去，不要通过电子邮件发送笑话和另类内容，也不要真的试图让这些公司缺乏我们的材料，向他们证明我们的材料在这个不断变化的行业中有多么有价值，在这个行业中，我们的报酬不足，我们的价值被贬低，我们被认为是理所当然的。
And that those things mattered and we had to do it, but it was so weird.
这些事情很重要，我们必须这样做，但这太奇怪了。
And then that was it.
然后就这样了。
That was it for three months.
就这样过了三个月。
You had a several month break too, at that point.
那时你也有几个月的休息时间。
I was basically pushing Elliot around in a stroller at the Sony lot or more likely to do that.
我基本上是在索尼的停车场推着婴儿车推着埃利奥特，或者更有可能这样做。
I need to, I don't remember what I did during that.
我需要，我不记得那段时间我做了什么。
What are you doing for three months?
这三个月你在做什么？
It's like a black hole amount of time.
这就像黑洞一样的时间。
I mean, I think I might have gone to Peru for another adventure.
我的意思是，我想我可能会去秘鲁进行另一次冒险。
I might have gone to Peru.
我可能去了秘鲁。
And this old man, he musted me, fell in love with you, New York City.
这位老人，他强迫我，爱上了你，纽约市。
And now, commercials.
现在，广告。
Hi, I'm Alex Goldman, host of the Hyper-Fixed Podcast.
大家好，我是 Alex Goldman，Hyper-Fixed 播客的主持人。
Each week, we take listeners' problems and try to solve them for them.
每周，我们都会收集听众的问题并尝试为他们解决。
Problems like, I'm 30 and I'm scared to drive in New York.
诸如此类的问题，我已经 30 岁了，我害怕在纽约开车。
Or, why can't I adjust the volume of my car stereo when I'm in reverse?
或者，为什么我倒车时无法调节汽车音响的音量？
We also solve non-car-related problems.
我们还解决与汽车无关的问题。
If you have a problem, not only will we fix it, we'll expose the hidden systems that caused that problem in the first place.
如果您遇到问题，我们不仅会修复它，还会首先暴露导致该问题的隐藏系统。
That's the Hyper-Fixed Podcast from Radiotopia.
这是来自 Radiotopia 的 Hyper-Fixed 播客。
Find it wherever you find podcasts or at hyperfixedpod.com.
无论您在哪里找到播客或在 hyperfixedpod.com 上都可以找到它。
End of commercials?
广告完结了？
Back to show.
返回展示。
What month was this?
这是几月？
This was December?
这是十二月？
Alec, when was it?
亚历克，那是什么时候？
It was, I think it was 2007, right?
那是，我想那是2007年，对吧？
I feel like it was November.
我感觉已经是十一月了。
It was released in December.
它于十二月发布。
I don't know what that means for when it was.
我不知道这对于当时来说意味着什么。
I think we pencils down maybe in sometime in November.
我想我们可能会在十一月的某个时候写下来。
Am I right?
我说得对吗？
What day did the writers go?
作家们哪天去的？
Oh, okay.
哦好的。
The strike began on November 5th.
罢工于11月5日开始。
November 5th, okay.
11月5日，好吧。
I had the right month.
我度过了正确的月份。
February 12th.
2 月 12 日。
Yeah.
是的。
Oh, I think it was in Peru and I had to get back for us.
哦，我想那是在秘鲁，我必须回去接我们。
Being.
存在。
To do no tomorrow.
不做明天。
To do the next episode.
去做下一集。
To do no tomorrow.
不做明天。
Yeah.
是的。
And we were not that, I remember we were not that far ahead too.
我们不是那样的，我记得我们也没有领先那么远。
And we'll get to this in the next episode, but we had that.
我们将在下一集中讨论这一点，但我们已经做到了。
Oh yeah, cause you guys that had to sprint for the rest.
哦，是的，因为你们必须冲刺剩下的时间。
The other contract, the other like, what am I trying to say, packed to the writers packed was, you're not supposed to sit there stockpiling scripts.
另一份合同，另一份合同，我想说的是，打包给编剧的是，你不应该坐在那里储存剧本。
You're not supposed to be like, I'm out picketing, but really I'm hiding in my office and writing the next 10 episodes.
你不应该说，我在外面纠察，但实际上我是躲在办公室里写接下来的 10 集。
hoping that with the strike ends, we didn't do that.
希望罢工结束后，我们不会这样做。
We had some ideas, we probably had some starts and some stories past this, but it wasn't much.
我们有一些想法，我们可能有一些开始和一些过去的故事，但并不多。
I think maybe we had the beginnings of a couple other scripts because this was the middle of the season.
我想也许我们已经开始了其他几个剧本，因为当时正值赛季中期。
This is the part where you start to run out of your head start and you start to like lose your lead.
这是你开始失去领先优势并且开始喜欢失去领先地位的部分。
And the Pac-Man is just catching up the each pellet is being eaten by Pac-Man.
吃豆人正在追赶吃豆人吃掉的每个颗粒。
And episode, episode, episode, and we were not far ahead.
一集，一集，一集，我们就领先了不远。
So when we came out of that strike almost three months later, We wound up doing, this is was episode 11 and this was a strike shortened 20 episode season.
因此，当我们在大约三个月后摆脱罢工时，我们最终做了，这是第 11 集，这是一个缩短了 20 集的罢工季。
This is the shortest season in the history of how much mother it's usually 22 or more often 24.
这是历史上最短的赛季，通常是 22 岁，或更常见的是 24 岁。
This was 20, but so we needed to do nine episodes in about 10 and a half weeks.
这是 20 集，但我们需要在大约 10 周半的时间内制作 9 集。
Once the storm, when the strike ended, it was.
一旦暴风雨，当罢工结束时，它就结束了。
Had you broken other stories like did you know?
你知道其他故事吗？
I think we had a couple, I think we had a couple of outlines.
我想我们有几个，我想我们有几个大纲。
Yeah.
是的。
And maybe the beginnings of a couple of scripts, but not a lot.
也许是几个脚本的开始，但不是很多。
Did you know, were you already in talks with Britney Spears to be on the show?
你知道吗，你已经在和布兰妮·斯皮尔斯商谈参加这个节目了吗？
No, that all came together super crazy fast as we came out of the strike.
不，当我们结束罢工时，所有这些都以非常疯狂的速度聚集在一起。
We'd had probably the outline for that one because that's only a couple episodes past this.
我们可能已经有了那个的大纲，因为那只是过去的几集。
That's what's so crazy.
这就是疯狂的原因。
We came out of the strike with Britney Spears.
我们和布兰妮·斯皮尔斯一起走出了罢工。
Well, it's not the next episode?
呃，这不是下一集吗？
It's not, no, it's no tomorrow is the next one after this.
不，不，不，明天就是这之后的下一个。
Oh, no tomorrow, right, right, right, right, right.
哦，没有明天，对，对，对，对，对。
It's the next one after that, I think, right?
我想这就是下一篇了，对吗？
It's not, it's actually right after that.
不是的，实际上是在那之后。
Yeah, so it's, we had, I think we would have had an outline or maybe even an early draft and that's what, So we had something to show Britney Spears as people and I think they reached out and wanted to have her on the show.
是的，所以，我们有，我想我们会有一个大纲，甚至可能是一个早期草稿，就是这样，所以我们有一些东西来展示布兰妮·斯皮尔斯作为一个人，我认为他们伸出援手并希望让她参加演出。
And yeah, it was amazing how fast things had to move on the B side of that strike.
是的，令人惊讶的是，这次罢工的 B 面的进展速度如此之快。
Yeah.
是的。
You know, a couple of things just in this episode.
你知道，这一集中有几件事。
I feel like a lot of shows, like this is a great episode for Charlene, for Wendy the Waitress.
我觉得有很多节目，就像这对夏琳和女服务员温迪来说是很棒的一集。
Yeah, it's Wendy the Waitress.
是的，这是女服务员温迪。
Charlene Amoya is really great in this episode.
夏琳·阿莫亚（Charlene Amoya）在这一集里真的很棒。
Yeah, she's so funny, and she's so charming.
是的，她很有趣，而且很迷人。
No, Charlene.
不，夏琳。
There was also like, you know, like her and Carl, they were like the Gunther of their friends' coffee shop.
还有，你知道，就像她和卡尔一样，他们就像朋友咖啡馆里的冈瑟。
Yeah, they were.
是的，他们是。
Yeah, man.
是的，伙计。
And I feel like there's something almost like when writers, like, assistants get promoted.
我觉得就像作家助理晋升一样。
Like sometimes you have someone who, they're not background players, they have a character's name, they get a couple jokes.
就像有时你会遇到一些人，他们不是背景玩家，他们有一个角色的名字，他们会得到几个笑话。
But then you realize like, oh wait, these are secret weapons to really fill out the world.
但后来你意识到，哦等等，这些是真正充实世界的秘密武器。
Yeah, she's great in this episode, and that was another serendipitous thing where someone who really knew the world of our show and had been in so many episodes and had had some stuff to do and some episodes and less than others.
是的，她在这一集里表现得很好，这是另一个偶然的事情，一个真正了解我们节目世界的人，参加过很多集，有一些事情要做，有些集比其他集少。
Now she got a very featured role in this one where if she were just somebody who came in and it was their first time on How Much Mother, maybe it wouldn't have been as good.
现在她在这部剧中扮演了一个非常有特色的角色，如果她只是一个进来的人，而且这是他们第一次出演《多少妈妈》，也许不会那么好。
We weren't rewriting that person.
我们并没有重写那个人。
She knew the assignment.
她知道这个任务。
Yeah, exactly.
是的，完全正确。
Yeah.
是的。
I also love, Wendy the waitress, the alliteration of it is terrific.
我也喜欢女服务员温迪，它的头韵很棒。
Like it's so simple.
好像事情就是这么简单。
I need the way to raise this type of nonsense.
我需要一种方式来提出这种废话。
It's so far in the like that way.
到目前为止都是这样。
Yeah.
是的。
It's like a children's show.
这就像一场儿童表演。
When do they dress?
他们什么时候穿衣服？
Yeah, yeah.
是啊是啊。
It's like Mrs. Playhouse.
就像剧场夫人一样。
Yeah.
是的。
Yeah, Mr. Rogers.
是的，罗杰斯先生。
But also like another powerful narrative technique that I think you see this a lot in the theater, but you guys used it.
但也像另一种强大的叙事技巧，我想你在剧院里经常看到这种技巧，但你们使用了它。
It's like we don't know Stella yet.
就好像我们还不认识斯特拉。
We haven't seen Stella.
我们还没见过斯特拉。
Yeah, it's funny.
是的，这很有趣。
It's like a really powerful, like she's like an off stage.
这就像一个非常强大的人，就像她在台下一样。
She's the shark in Joss, she's much disgust but not seen.
她是《乔斯》中的鲨鱼，她很令人厌恶但又不见踪影。
And so by the time you see her two episodes from now, you kind of have a little bit of a narrative relationship with her.
所以当你从现在开始看到她的两集时，你和她已经有了一点叙事关系。
There's a ramp up.
有一个斜坡上升。
Yeah, you know Ted really wanted her, and there was a huge debate philosophical symposium on whether he showed or shouldn't date her, and you never see her.
是的，你知道特德真的想要她，关于他是否表现出或不应该与她约会，有一场大型辩论哲学研讨会，但你永远不会见到她。
And you have to, it's very like waiting for her to go.
你必须这样做，这就像在等她走。
She's the good girl, waiting for some.
她是个好女孩，正在等待一些人。
Yeah, we had a minute.
是的，我们有一分钟的时间。
I love that.
我喜欢那个。
And then you have these guest stars, you know, Kristin and forgive me, his.
然后还有这些客串明星，你知道，克里斯汀，请原谅我，他的。
Great, I don't know his name, I'll give you a shout out to him.
太好了，我不知道他的名字，我会大声喊他。
He was Kristin and I don't know his name, we're great.
他是克里斯汀，我不知道他的名字，我们很棒。
I never met them, so I don't know.
我从未见过他们，所以我不知道。
I should know.
我应该知道。
We meet them at the, by this point in the series, I think we were getting tapes of people, we weren't sitting in the casting room, you know, meeting people, but the writer of the episode would be, although it wasn't, Cara was more on this episode than me until neither of us was.
我们在剧中见到他们时，我想我们收到了人们的录像带，我们不是坐在选角室里，你知道，会见人们，但这一集的编剧会是，尽管事实并非如此，卡拉比我更关注这一集，直到我们都没有。
But Kristin Schall had already done Flight of the Concordes, right?
但克里斯汀·夏尔已经拍过《协和式飞机的飞行》了，对吧？
I think so, and maybe the Daily Show.
我想是的，也许还有《每日秀》。
She was on the Daily Show.
她参加了《每日秀》。
Yeah, she was on the Daily Show.
是的，她参加了《每日秀》。
I remember when we knew her and thought she was funny.
我记得我们认识她的时候，觉得她很有趣。
She is a very singular presence.
她是一个非常独特的存在。
Like, I've always thought she was hilarious.
比如说，我一直觉得她很搞笑。
Instantly has a thing, and they're very likable.
立刻就有了东西，而且他们非常讨人喜欢。
And yeah, they were great.
是的，他们很棒。
He's MacArthur, Kristin Schall, Charlene's great in it.
他是麦克阿瑟，克里斯汀·夏尔，夏琳在其中很出色。
I like how the neighbors genuinely turns into horror movie.
我喜欢邻居们真正变成恐怖电影的方式。
Oh my God, and they're just over-tend shoulder there.
天啊，他们简直太劳累了。
Yeah, it's through the fisheye, yeah.
是的，这是通过鱼眼，是的。
Yeah, so it's great, it's a really good, I'm really happy with how the episode came out in that we like, we were- No, it's best case scenario given the circumstances.
是的，所以这很棒，真的很好，我真的很高兴这一集的结果，因为我们喜欢，我们 - 不，考虑到目前的情况，这是最好的情况。
Best case scenario given the circumstances and it's good that it was a solid structure because I think the structure carries it through.
考虑到当时的情况，这是最好的情况，而且它是一个坚固的结构，这很好，因为我认为这个结构可以承载它。
I think there's a moment and there's a kind of film like cinematic language to this episode, that even minus the several days of extra joke writing, we would have normally done, it still works.
我认为这一集有一个时刻，有一种像电影语言一样的电影，即使减去几天额外的笑话编写，我们通常会这样做，它仍然有效。
Yeah.
是的。
I could just tell you that we have, we have Hayes MacArthur as Kurt, Kristen Shaw and John Sloan as Michael Sloan.
我可以告诉你，我们有海耶斯·麦克阿瑟饰演库尔特，克里斯汀·肖和约翰·斯隆饰演迈克尔·斯隆。
John Sloan, okay, they really solid cast in this and we got to rewrite them zero, we got to give them zero notes or thoughts and they were still great.
约翰·斯隆，好吧，他们在这方面的演员阵容非常扎实，我们必须对他们进行零重写，我们必须给他们零笔记或想法，他们仍然很棒。
So maybe we're the problem.
所以也许我们才是问题所在。
Maybe writers are the problem.
也许作家才是问题所在。
Kristen Shaw is asked all the time, what was it like to work with Craig Thomas?
克里斯汀·肖总是被问到，与克雷格·托马斯合作感觉如何？
Yeah, I know.
是的，我知道。
And she...
而她...
So a couple of things that really struck me that I thought were just, these are my things that I doodle that I find are very funny.
有几件事让我印象深刻，我认为这些是我涂鸦的东西，我发现它们非常有趣。
My friend Dion and I had, we would keep a list for years of things that are always funny.
我和我的朋友迪翁，我们会列出多年来总是有趣的事情的清单。
One of them was mini air guitar.
其中之一是迷你空气吉他。
Yeah, mini air guitar, yeah.
是的，迷你空气吉他，是的。
And napkins and collars while you're eating is for some reason hilarious.
吃饭时的餐巾和项圈不知为何很搞笑。
And Barney was, were they eating wings at the beginning of the episode?
巴尼是，他们在这一集开始时吃的是翅膀吗？
Yeah, that's right.
是的，没错。
They're eating, yeah.
他们正在吃饭，是的。
That's funny.
那很好笑。
That is a funny observation.
这是一个有趣的观察。
I didn't even notice that, but it is funny.
我什至没有注意到这一点，但这很有趣。
I like, I really like when Neil does his.
我喜欢，我真的很喜欢尼尔做他的事情。
Okay, like his like, I'm telling, I'm just okay.
好吧，就像他一样，我告诉你，我很好。
He's appealing to someone's reason, but his ask is always insane.
他诉诸某人的理由，但他的要求总是疯狂的。
It's unreasonable.
这是不合理的。
Yes.
是的。
Yeah.
And it's actually the other person is being a dick, even though it's like, you're not agreeing to my lie.
事实上，对方是个混蛋，尽管这就像，你不同意我的谎言。
Just agree to my thing I'm wrong about.
只要同意我的错误就可以了。
Why are you resisting this wrong thing that I'm saying?
你为什么要抵制我说的这个错误的话？
Ted fixing his hair was just great.
特德整理头发真是太棒了。
You were really funny with that.
你真的很有趣。
That was Barney knew it would thwart him too.
巴尼知道这也会阻碍他。
He couldn't leave that apart.
他不能把它抛开。
I like that Ted wasn't like, ah fuck this, I'm leaving again.
我喜欢特德不会说，操，我又要走了。
It was like dude, like he had to go back and fix it.
就像老兄，他必须回去修复它。
Ted Barney knew that wasn't Achilles heel for Ted.
特德·巴尼知道这不是特德的致命弱点。
Yeah, Ted had a guys, guys, guys in the bar.
是的，特德在酒吧里有一群人。
Guys, guys, guys, I very much thought guys, guys, guys, and Michael Sharer, sister director would always say that and that became anytime the word guys was in the script.
伙计们，伙计们，伙计们，我非常认为伙计们，伙计们，伙计们，姐妹导演迈克尔·沙雷尔总是会这么说，而剧本中只要出现“伙计们”这个词，这句话就变成了这样。
You'd add two more.
你还得再加两个。
Yeah, I don't think we even bothered writing it, guys, guys, because we knew you guys would do so.
是的，我认为我们甚至懒得写它，伙计们，因为我们知道你们会这样做。
No, I think at some point you started writing it in there.
不，我想在某个时候你开始把它写在那里。
Do we start writing?
我们开始写作吗？
I think so.
我想是的。
Yeah, yeah.
是啊是啊。
I like she's gullible.
我喜欢她容易上当受骗。
I'm bored.
我很无聊。
We're perfect for each other.
我们非常适合彼此。
Yeah.
是的。
Barney's Associate Path.
巴尼的副手路径。
The runner of, yeah, well, I think it'll be OK.
是的，好吧，我想这会没问题的。
I think it'll be OK.
我想会没事的。
That's also human nature, right?
这也是人性吧？
but it's like you can hear all the logic you want.
但就好像你可以听到你想要的所有逻辑。
Yeah, it's also, it's also Adam McKay is nothing funnier than being confidently wrong.
是的，亚当·麦凯也没有什么比自信地犯错更有趣的了。
Positively wrong.
肯定是错误的。
Everyone is so comfortable.
每个人都那么舒服。
There's so much smugness to us human beings, right?
我们人类有太多的自鸣得意，对吧？
We're like, get a load of what that asshole is doing.
我们就像，了解一下那个混蛋在做什么。
I'm gonna do this thing that's the exact same, but for me, it's gonna be different.
我要做的事情是完全相同的，但对我来说，它会有所不同。
For me, it's gonna be different.
对我来说，情况会有所不同。
Yeah, that is such a human nature thing.
是的，这就是人性的事情。
The hockey guy that she's, and then Barney says, what's the opposite of name trapping?
她是个曲棍球运动员，然后巴尼说，名字陷阱的反义词是什么？
Yes, what's the opposite of name trapping?
是的，名称陷阱的反面是什么？
that was Jerry.
那是杰瑞。
Okay.
好的。
I think I might have thrown that in there or Carter, but I think maybe me because Jerry Mulligan at the late show with David Letterman, but also say that just if someone would be like, well, I'm Bob Bob Bob Bob Bob.
我想我可能会把它扔在那里或卡特，但我想也许是因为杰瑞·穆里根在大卫·莱特曼的晚间秀中，但我也说，如果有人会说，好吧，我是鲍勃·鲍勃·鲍勃·鲍勃。
Jerry Mulligan's a writer on late show with David Letterman.
杰里·穆里根是大卫·莱特曼晚间节目的作家。
And he would just he would just say it like in life and conversation.
他只会像在生活和谈话中那样说出来。
They'd be like, well, the other day I was hanging out with Bob Bob Bob.
他们会说，好吧，有一天我和鲍勃·鲍勃·鲍勃一起出去玩。
What's the exact opposite of name dropping?
与删除名字完全相反的是什么？
It's just like Jerry just shitting on somebody for no reason.
就像杰瑞无缘无故地对某人拉屎一样。
It's very, very funny to you, Jerry Mulligan.
这对你来说非常非常有趣，杰里·穆里根。
I think that was just stealing stealing a Mulligan.
我认为那只是偷窃Mulligan。
Yeah.
是的。
I liked when Marshall did charades of doing charades.
我喜欢马歇尔猜谜语。
Yes.
是的。
That's also a Russian nesting doll of like a joke.
这也是一个像笑话一样的俄罗斯套娃。
The whole thing is Russian nesting dolls.
整个事情就是俄罗斯套娃。
It's thematically intertwined throughout.
它在主题上贯穿始终。
Yeah.
是的。
When Jordana was watching them play charades, she said, this is my worst nightmare.
当乔丹娜看着他们玩字谜游戏时，她说，这是我最糟糕的噩梦。
Like she doesn't want, actually, we love our neighbors, by the way.
顺便说一句，就像她不想的那样，事实上，我们爱我们的邻居。
Yeah.
是的。
But she, I don't think she wants to play charades with them every night.
但她，我想她不想每天晚上和他们玩字谜游戏。
know and you can't walk out your door.
知道了，你就不能走出家门。
I mean, I love that Marshall and Lily essentially got a we had sex with the coworker as a couple.
我的意思是，我喜欢马歇尔和莉莉本质上与同事作为情侣发生了性关系。
I mean, we found the version that really was essentially the same thing.
我的意思是，我们发现这个版本本质上是一样的。
Charades are the sex.
猜谜游戏就是性。
Not sex.
不是性。
Charades, but it's the same violation.
字谜游戏，但同样是违规行为。
It's the same.
是一样的。
It's exactly the same.
完全一样。
It's a couple of versions.
这是几个版本。
Yeah, I thought the Neil did a really funny subtle thing when he messes up my hair and then he has to wipe it.
是的，我认为尼尔做了一件非常有趣的微妙的事情，他弄乱了我的头发，然后他必须把它擦干净。
He always has to wipe off whatever the paste is in his hair.
他总是必须擦掉头发上的糊状物。
Every time he did it, he did that.
每次他这样做，他就这样做。
He had like a little, a little kerchief.
他有一小块小头巾。
I wrote down that Wendy is just so appealing, Charlene was just so great.
我写下温迪太有吸引力了，夏琳太棒了。
It was great.
太棒了。
What is, what was once my jungle is now my zoo?
什么是，曾经我的丛林现在变成了我的动物园？
Yes.
是的。
It's a great line.
这是一条很棒的线。
Yeah.
是的。
I think Carter headed this one out more than me, so I'm going to do many credit, but.
我认为卡特在这一场比赛中的表现比我更多，所以我会做出很多功劳，但是。
Wendy the Waitress hyphen Stinson, we already said such a funny line.
女服务员温迪连字符斯廷森，我们已经说过这样有趣的台词了。
Barney's such a dick when he breaks up with Wendy.
巴尼和温迪分手后真是个混蛋。
Oh my God, he is.
天哪，他是。
I think that you guys were like, almost like a child testing limits.
我认为你们就像一个测试极限的孩子。
Like I feel like sometimes you, you punish Barney for his stuff and other times you just let him be horrible.
就像我觉得有时你会因为巴尼的事情而惩罚他，而有时你却让他变得可怕。
but I think like sometimes it really does make you go, ooh.
但我认为有时它确实会让你走，哦。
No, I know, and I much prefer, I'm always waiting for the karma and the comeuppance.
不，我知道，而且我更愿意，我一直在等待业力和报应。
And when it doesn't happen, I always feel like a little bit, like we need a shower at the end of it.
当它没有发生时，我总是感觉有点像我们需要在结束时洗个澡。
It's much better.
好多了。
And also, Neil's so funny at getting the comeuppance.
而且，尼尔得到报应的方式也很有趣。
It's better when that happens.
当这种情况发生时就更好了。
I guess we couldn't do it every single time, but I prefer it when there is.
我想我们不可能每次都这样做，但我更喜欢有的时候这样做。
What is the end of the comeuppance is that she didn't really give as much of a shit about him as he thought.
报应的结局是，她并没有像他想象的那样真正在意他。
But come up, it's this kind of like, she has moved on and he wants to believe that he's being poisoned because she's so hard work.
但说起来，就像这样，她已经继续前进，他想相信他被毒害了，因为她工作太努力了。
She kind of doesn't care at that point.
那时她有点不在乎。
This is something we'll definitely talk about in the next episode, No Tomorrow, which is really about karma and conscience and, you know, consequences, yeah.
这是我们肯定会在下一集《没有明天》中讨论的内容，这实际上是关于业力和良心，以及后果，是的。
But there is something about how I met your mother and I think this makes people feel good, which is it's a moral universe.
但我遇到你母亲的过程中有一些东西，我认为这让人感觉很好，这是一个道德世界。
It's not a nihilistic cynical, every man for himself.
这不是一个虚无主义的愤世嫉俗者，每个人都只顾自己。
Like, I really think that goodness is rewarded in the long run, not always in the short term, but goodness is rewarded on this show.
就像，我真的认为从长远来看，善良会得到回报，而不总是在短期内得到回报，但在这个节目中，善良会得到回报。
Virtue is rewarded on this show.
美德在这个节目中得到回报。
I think it's benevolent universe where bad things still happen, but your friends will help you get through those bad things.
我认为这是一个仁慈的宇宙，坏事仍然会发生，但你的朋友会帮助你度过那些坏事。
And I think sometimes when Barney is so kind of venal or Machiavellian, it almost like it disrupts the moral universe universe for a moment, and at the same time, it's really fun to watch people misbehave.
我认为有时当巴尼如此贪婪或马基雅维利时，它几乎就像它暂时扰乱了道德宇宙，同时，看到人们行为不端真的很有趣。
Yeah, no, but I mean, in the larger moral arc of the series, it's interesting to see when Barney is forced to confront himself a little bit rather than getting away with murder all the time.
是的，不，但我的意思是，在该系列更大的道德弧线中，有趣的是看到巴尼被迫面对自己一点，而不是一直逃脱谋杀。
Yeah.
是的。
I think we're living in a little bit of an era in 2026 where people, a lot of Barney's are getting away with a lot.
我认为我们生活在 2026 年的一个时代，人们，很多 Barney's 都逍遥法外。
Yeah.
是的。
I find it somewhat disconcerting to watch those episodes in this climate that we're in right now, because Barney is supposed to be a parody of that and a warning against me.
我发现在我们现在所处的环境下观看这些剧集有点令人不安，因为巴尼应该是对这一点的模仿和对我的警告。
But suddenly he's Secretary of Defense.
但突然间他就成了国防部长。
Secretary of War.
战争部长。
Secretary of War, forgive me.
战争部长，请原谅我。
Yeah, the slow-mo hamburger slap is really funny of him getting the burger out of market.
是的，他把汉堡赶出市场的慢镜头拍汉堡真的很有趣。
And I'm so glad it's funny, it's like, it's a slap.
我很高兴这很有趣，就像是一巴掌。
Like it is a slap.
就像是一巴掌。
It's a slap.
这是一巴掌。
I know it blurs the lines a little bit.
我知道这有点模糊了界限。
right?
正确的？
Oh shit, I know.
哦，该死，我知道。
And I gotta say, sometimes an episode, like for this episode, I was like, wait, am I just fixing my hair all the time and listening to my friends yell at me?
我得说，有时一集，就像这一集，我就想，等等，我是不是一直在整理头发，听我的朋友对我大喊大叫？
Like, you know, you'd have that feeling.
就像，你知道，你会有那种感觉。
But then you guys, every third or fourth episode, you'd give me such a good third act.
但是你们，每隔第三或第四集，你们就会给我一个很好的第三幕。
You know, like such a good, and Jordana got real quiet when I was doing the, you know, like, I don't care, like I'm gonna take a chance, right?
你知道，当我这样做的时候，乔丹娜变得非常安静，你知道，就像，我不在乎，就像我要冒险，对吧？
That whole monologue was just, I don't know, I was really like, I really like that.
整个独白只是，我不知道，我真的很喜欢。
There's the guy, there's the guy I love playing.
就是这个人，就是我喜欢玩的那个人。
Yeah, there's Ted being not reactive, but active.
是的，特德不是被动的，而是主动的。
And here's, yeah, there's the romantic hero that was in the DNA.
是的，这就是 DNA 中的浪漫英雄。
That's the energy that our opening recording was talking about, too, to people chasing something, people leaving and something and chasing and Ted gives a speech of like, I'm gonna go be wrong, but you have to.
这也是我们的开场录音所谈论的能量，人们追逐某事，人们离开，追逐某事，特德发表了类似的演讲，我会犯错，但你必须这样做。
You have to, you have to, you have to take action and learn things.
你必须，你必须，你必须采取行动并学习东西。
That's how this works.
这就是它的工作原理。
He's really like, so there's this great Australian artist named New Buffalo, and she has this really fantastic song called Emotional Champ.
他真的很喜欢，所以有一位伟大的澳大利亚艺术家，名叫 New Buffalo，她有一首非常棒的歌曲，叫做 Emotional Champ。
Do you know this song?
你知道这首歌吗？
No, I don't.
不，我不。
New Buffalo is a really great Australian artist named Sally Seltman.
New Buffalo 是一位非常伟大的澳大利亚艺术家，名叫 Sally Seltman。
She opened for me and Ben on tour.
她在巡演中为我和本开场。
She's fantastic, but she records sometimes as New Buffalo.
她很棒，但有时她会以 New Buffalo 的身份录制。
So she was really good friends with Claire Danes.
所以她和克莱尔·丹尼斯真的是好朋友。
I know this because Ben Lee, who I made music with, Claire is his ex, and so New Buffalo, she wrote a song because Claire's manager or agent said, you know, we need to get you apart.
我知道这一点是因为本·李，我和他一起创作音乐，克莱尔是他的前任，所以新布法罗，她写了一首歌，因为克莱尔的经理或经纪人说，你知道，我们需要让你们分开。
You need to play like a champion, that's what we need.
你需要像冠军一样打球，这就是我们所需要的。
And she met like an Olympian and Claire didn't understand, she goes like an emotional champ.
她像一位奥运选手一样相遇，克莱尔不明白，她就像一位情感冠军。
She was like, like, that's my gift, right, is being emotional, like an emotional champ.
她说，这就是我的天赋，对吧，就是情绪化，就像一个情绪冠军。
And she told her friend who wrote a song called Emotional Champ, which is, I think, such a good title.
她告诉她的朋友，她写了一首名为《情感冠军》的歌曲，我认为这是一个很好的标题。
We should put that in the show notes, that song.
我们应该把它放在演出笔记中，那首歌。
Ted is an emotional champ.
特德是一位情感冠军。
He's an emotional champ.
他是一个情感冠军。
You know what I'm saying?
你知道我在说什么吗？
It's the resilience thing.
这是韧性的事情。
He's an emotional champ.
他是一个情感冠军。
He's an emotional rocky.
他是一个情绪不稳定的人。
And he gets the shit beat out of him.
他被打败了。
You know what I mean?
你知道我的意思？
In the very next episode, he literally gets the shit beat out.
在下一集中，他真的被打败了。
He literally is an auto bar and then he has like wounds show for his, like him putting himself out there.
他确实是一个汽车酒吧，然后他的伤口就显现出来了，就像他把自己放在那里一样。
And I just, I really applauded.
我只是，我真的鼓掌。
I was really happy that, you know, he's got his core.
我真的很高兴，你知道，他有他的核心。
He's spending the whole episode fussing with his hair to get it perfect.
他整集都在忙着打理自己的头发，让头发变得完美。
But like, there's just something like you guys always in the final analysis, you always let him be an emotional champ.
但归根结底，你们总是让他成为情感冠军。
And I was really, I was really happy about that.
我真的，我真的很高兴。
I'm so glad it felt that way to you.
我很高兴你有这种感觉。
Because this week we're discussing the platinum rule.
因为本周我们正在讨论白金规则。
We have reached the end-ish of our show.
我们的演出已经接近尾声了。
This is a section we call the sea block.
这是我们称之为海块的部分。
This is the haunted sea block.
这就是闹鬼的海域。
I like that, Alec.
我喜欢这样，亚历克。
The sea block.
海块。
We love the girl.
我们爱这个女孩。
I just have a girl named the sea block.
我只有一个叫海块的女孩。
We love hearing from fans of the show listeners of this podcast.
我们很高兴听到这个播客的节目听众的粉丝的来信。
If you would like to record a voice note and to tell us about your experience, your love of your relationship with how I met your mother or our podcast, how we made your mother, go to how we made your mother.com, go up to contact, follow the directions.
如果您想录制语音留言并告诉我们您的经历、您对我如何认识您母亲或我们的播客的关系的热爱、我们如何造就了您的母亲，请访问我们如何造就了您的 mother.com，前往联系方式，按照说明进行操作。
You can either drop us a voice note or a written note.
您可以向我们发送语音留言或书面留言。
We love to hear from you.
我们很高兴收到您的来信。
We open our show with a voice note.
我们用语音注释开始我们的节目。
close it with a written note.
用书面注释将其关闭。
Today we are actually closing the two.
今天我们实际上关闭了这两个。
We got two for the price of one, Alec insisted that both of these be read.
我们以一本的价格买了两本，亚历克坚持要读这两本。
We have not read these yet.
我们还没有读过这些。
Craig and I, but we're very excited to.
克雷格和我，但我们对此感到非常兴奋。
Craig's going to read the first one.
克雷格要读第一本。
I'm going to read the second one and let's hear what you have to say.
我要读第二篇，让我们听听你要说什么。
Let's do it.
我们开始做吧。
This is this letter is from Tilda from Denmark.
这封信是来自丹麦的蒂尔达寄来的。
Thank you for the pronunciation of that tilde from Denmark.
感谢您提供来自丹麦的波浪号的发音。
It says, hi, Craig, Josh and Alec.
它说，嗨，克雷格、乔什和亚历克。
Alec, shout out.
亚历克，大声喊出来。
Hi.
你好。
And everyone else behind the scenes.
还有幕后的其他所有人。
First of all, thank you for making this podcast.
首先，感谢您制作这个播客。
I've always been the geeky person that watched bonus material on the DVDs back when it was a thing.
我一直是个极客，当 DVD 还流行时，我就观看 DVD 上的奖励材料。
Alec made that material, by the way, for how much a mother.
顺便说一句，亚历克制作这个材料的价格是一个母亲的价格。
Well, thank you.
嗯，谢谢。
You're welcome.
不客气。
This rewatch podcast is sort of the modern version of the DVD bonus material.
这个重播播客有点像 DVD 奖励材料的现代版本。
Well, it's appropriate because Alec doing this too.
嗯，这是合适的，因为亚历克也这样做。
I love to learn about film making the process and the decisions that were made along the way.
我喜欢了解电影制作的过程以及在此过程中做出的决定。
That interest led me to getting a master's degree in dramaturgy, back then hoping to find a job in writing or producing a film or a theater.
这种兴趣促使我获得了戏剧学硕士学位，当时我希望能找到一份编剧或制作电影或戏剧的工作。
I fell in love with him because of the fun and often surprising ways to tell the stories, like in the Pineapple incident, Ted Mosby architect, and one of my favorites, the platinum rule.
我爱上他是因为他讲故事的方式很有趣，而且常常令人惊讶，比如菠萝事件、建筑师特德·莫斯比，以及我最喜欢的铂金规则之一。
I wrote my thesis about the unreliable narrator, and though him wasn't my subject of analysis, I think it's still influenced my decision and interest in this specific storytelling technique.
我写的论文是关于不可靠的叙述者的，尽管他不是我的分析对象，但我认为它仍然影响了我对这种特定的讲故事技巧的决定和兴趣。
I also want to let you know what Hemium means to me right now in these days.
我还想让你知道 Hemium 对我来说意味着什么。
My husband and I have a child with special needs.
我丈夫和我有一个有特殊需要的孩子。
We love him and we try to navigate the struggles of the life we're now living, but when the day is over, we are done.
我们爱他，我们努力克服现在生活中的挣扎，但当这一天结束时，我们就完了。
There's so little relational energy left.
剩下的关系能量已经所剩无几了。
God, that's a good phrase for this.
天啊，这句话用得好。
So little relational energy left that I don't have any left to engage with new people and not even fictional ones.
剩下的关系能量如此之少，以至于我没有任何余力来与新朋友交往，甚至是虚构的人。
most nights I just re-watch an episode or two of Hemium.
大多数晚上我只是重看一两集 Hemium。
That way I get to hang out with my old pals Ted, Marshall, Lily, Robin, and Barney.
这样我就可以和我的老朋友泰德、马歇尔、莉莉、罗宾和巴尼一起出去玩。
They ask nothing of me other than 20 minutes of attention and in return they make me laugh, cry, and root for them while they remind me of hope and love and endurance.
他们只要求我给予 20 分钟的关注，作为回报，他们让我笑、哭，为他们加油，同时让我想起希望、爱和忍耐。
I don't know if I believe the premise of everything happens for a reason or that the universe has some big plan.
我不知道我是否相信一切发生的前提都是有原因的，或者宇宙有什么大计划。
I have yet to see it in my own life.
我在自己的生活中还没有看到过。
But I like the Ted believes, and that it fuels his hope.
但我喜欢特德的信念，这激发了他的希望。
My own hope is kind of frayed and tattered, to be honest.
老实说，我自己的希望已经破灭了。
Life seems so far from how I thought it would be, both family and work, but I do try not to let the shadow of what didn't come, dim the light of what actually is.
生活似乎与我想象的样子相去甚远，无论是家庭还是工作，但我确实尽力不让未到来的阴影遮蔽实际的光芒。
That is something both Hemium and Hoemium remind me of.
Hemium 和 Hoemium 都让我想起了这一点。
And someday, when there's space in me for new fictional people, I want to check out your book, Greg.
有一天，当我有空间容纳新的虚构人物时，我想看看你的书，格雷格。
I would love to read a comedy about a special needs family, especially from your hand.
我很想读一部关于特殊需要家庭的喜剧，尤其是出自你之手。
It'll be no short of legendary, I expect.
我预计这将不乏传奇色彩。
Thanks for being my pals on my screen and in my ears.
感谢您成为我屏幕上和耳朵里的朋友。
Lots of love, Tilda.
充满爱，蒂尔达。
Wow, I'm very moved by that message.
哇，这个消息让我很感动。
I hope you do pick up the book, but I also understand how full your brain and your heart and your soul and every minute and every molecule is Tilda.
我希望你能拿起这本书，但我也明白你的大脑、你的心、你的灵魂、每一分钟、每一个分子都是蒂尔达的。
I'm sending you so much strength.
我给你送来了如此多的力量。
And I'm so happy the show is there for you.
我很高兴这个节目适合你。
Yeah, that was really beautiful.
是的，那真的很美。
Thank you so much.
太感谢了。
Here is our second letter.
这是我们的第二封信。
This is from Kateri from Denver.
这是来自丹佛的卡特里的。
Dear Alec, Craig, and Josh, it is nice, Alec, that people write to you.
亲爱的亚历克、克雷格和乔什，亚历克，很高兴有人给你写信。
It is nice.
这很好。
It's nice.
很好。
I'm embarrassed by my name being first in that email.
我对自己的名字出现在该电子邮件的第一位感到尴尬。
You should alphabetize them.
你应该按字母顺序排列它们。
This is alphabetized.
这是按字母顺序排列的。
Okay.
好的。
This is Dear Alec, Craig, and Josh, my name is Kateri and I am a long-term Hemium fan, a psychology professor, a wife, and a mother.
我是亲爱的 Alec、Craig 和 Josh，我叫 Kateri，是 Hemium 的长期粉丝、心理学教授、妻子和母亲。
I'm writing to make my case that the platinum rule is the best encapsulation of the series and that it is also a science-backed example of how art can overcome the human flaws of storytelling.
我写这封信是为了证明白金规则是该系列的最佳概括，也是一个有科学支持的例子，说明艺术如何克服人类讲故事的缺陷。
Now, remember, this is a psychology professor, so I'm very excited to be here.
现在，请记住，这是一位心理学教授，所以我很高兴来到这里。
I'm terrified that this is going to be a case for writers not being muted.
我担心这将成为作家不被静音的情况。
Oh, exactly.
哦，正是如此。
I don't know what's going to happen.
我不知道会发生什么。
I haven't imagined my seat here.
我没想到我的座位在这里。
The central lesson of the platinum rule is that there are some things that cannot be learned by verbal recounting alone, that one must experience instead.
白金法则的核心教训是，有些事情不能仅通过口头叙述来学习，而必须亲自经历。
This is supported by psychology and neuroscience.
这得到了心理学和神经科学的支持。
Learning that is viscerally experienced is more robust than learning that is transmitted with language, storytelling alone.
发自内心体验的学习比仅通过语言、讲故事来传播的学习更强大。
The nested structure is uniquely hymnium, quick cuts, layered flashbacks, wig work, all of it on work.
嵌套结构是独特的赞美诗、快速剪辑、分层闪回、假发工作，所有这些都在工作中。
Big props to the wig work in this episode, by the way.
顺便说一句，假发在这一集中发挥了重要作用。
All of it on point in creating a fugue-like satisfying balance of predictability and build.
所有这些都旨在创建可预测性和构建之间的类似赋格的令人满意的平衡。
The irony of the episode contains the broader message of the entire series.
这一集的讽刺意味包含了整个系列更广泛的信息。
Narrator Ted tries to teach this to them by telling them a story.
叙述者泰德试图通过给他们讲一个故事来教他们这一点。
Even older Ted still believes if his story is told well enough, it will spare his kids the sting of experience and convey the lesson in a safe contained way.
即使是年长的泰德仍然相信，如果他的故事讲得足够好，他的孩子就会免受经验的刺痛，并以安全的方式传达教训。
The rest of the episode tells us he would fail.
这一集的其余部分告诉我们他会失败。
Wow, I mean, it's a great point.
哇，我的意思是，这是一个很好的观点。
It is a great point.
这是一个很好的观点。
However, where Ted as a storyteller fails, the show as an art form sores because a TV show is able to partially hack the platinum rule.
然而，泰德作为一个讲故事的人失败了，而该节目作为一种艺术形式则出现了问题，因为电视节目能够部分打破白金规则。
Research shows that between learning from experience and storytelling is a middle ground, observational learning.
研究表明，从经验中学习和讲故事之间存在着中间立场，即观察性学习。
We learn better from watching, observing other people learn than we do from just hearing a story about it.
我们通过观看、观察其他人的学习效果比仅仅听故事学到的效果更好。
Observational learning is not quite as robust as experiential learning, but it can be quite close.
观察性学习不如体验式学习那么强大，但也可以非常接近。
So by inviting viewers to see themselves as the sixth friend in the McLaren's booth, the show is allowing millions of people to learn vicariously.
因此，通过邀请观众将自己视为迈凯伦展位上的第六位朋友，该节目让数百万人能够代替学习。
Observational learning contains just enough sting to learn, but in a removed, safer way.
观察学习包含足够的学习刺痛，但以一种消除的、更安全的方式。
Hemium viewers are learning older Ted's lesson even better than Luke and Penny will.
Hemium 观众比卢克和佩妮更好地学习了老泰德的教训。
I suspect the reason your show resonates with so many people is that the audience observes and indirectly experiences that a path of winding heartbreak can lead to joy, not just a story told, but a story showed.
我怀疑你的节目之所以能引起这么多人的共鸣，是因为观众观察到并间接体验到一条曲折的心碎之路可以带来欢乐，不仅仅是一个讲述的故事，而是一个展示的故事。
So thanks for creating an episode about experiential learning that uses observational learning to demonstrate that verbal learning has limited effectiveness.
因此，感谢您制作了有关体验式学习的一集，该集使用观察学习来证明口头学习的有效性有限。
Thanks for your thoughtful revisiting and vulnerability on the podcast.
感谢您对播客的深思熟虑的重访和脆弱性。
It has reignited and expanded my intellectual and emotional affection for the show.
它重新点燃并扩大了我对这部剧的理智和情感的喜爱。
Kateri Kates.
卡特里·凯特斯.
Oh my God.
我的天啊。
Wow.
哇。
That letter, this letter is a Russian nesting now.
那封信，这封信现在是俄罗斯人的嵌套。
I know.
我知道。
It's incredible.
太不可思议了。
Yeah.
是的。
Well done.
干得好。
Kateri.
卡泰里。
Do you know what's fun?
你知道什么好玩吗？
My God.
我的上帝。
I'm directing a movie hopefully next year that I didn't write.
希望明年我会导演一部不是我编剧的电影。
That's my first time directing a movie I didn't write.
这是我第一次导演一部不是我编剧的电影。
And I had such a good meeting with the writer, and he told me he texted his wife after the meeting and said, I think this guy understands my movie better than I understand my movie, which was great and lovely, but I could feel that in her letter is stuff that is inarguably true.
我和编剧进行了一次非常愉快的会面，他告诉我，他在会面后给他的妻子发了短信说，我认为这个人比我更了解我的电影，这部电影很棒而且很可爱，但我可以感觉到她信中的内容毫无疑问是真实的。
I think everything she said in that is inarguably true.
我认为她所说的一切都是无可争议的事实。
but it's not something that you, if you were interviewed about the platinum rule, like you would not be with it.
但如果您接受有关白金规则的采访，您不会不同意。
How about we just talk for 45 minutes less than 10 minutes.
我们就聊 45 分钟（不到 10 分钟）怎么样？
It didn't come close.
它并没有接近。
It didn't come close to that.
它远没有达到这一点。
It's genius, Kateria.
真是天才，凯特丽亚。
Yeah.
是的。
But I'm saying like, she has insight into what?
但我想说的是，她对什么有洞察力？
I mean, she has insights into what you guys were doing.
我的意思是，她对你们所做的事情有深入的了解。
Yes.
是的。
And the stuff that she's pointing out is in there.
她指出的东西就在那里。
It's not like, it's in there.
不像，它就在那里。
But do we know it's in there?
但我们知道它在那里吗？
We know it's in there.
我们知道它就在那里。
But it wasn't like you guys had some thesis statement on the wall saying observational learning versus experiential learning like I guess We knew about the experiential thing the the you're gonna hear a warning a Dire warning within a dire warning within a dire warning and Ted who is smart is still gonna go.
但这不像你们在墙上贴了一些论文陈述，说观察性学习与体验式学习，就像我猜我们知道体验式的事情一样，你会听到一个警告，一个可怕的警告，一个可怕的警告，一个可怕的警告，而聪明的特德仍然会去。
I think it's gonna be okay Yeah, I mean we knew that we were trying to sort of excavate that little pocket of human absurdity But the way this is laid out and the idea of observational versus experiential and the story being showed, not just told, viewers of the show are getting more than someone just hearing it, AKA to kids, this is really, this is wonderful.
我想会没问题的 是的，我的意思是我们知道我们正在尝试挖掘人类荒谬的那一小部分，但是这种方式的呈现方式，观察性与经验性的想法以及所展示的故事，而不仅仅是讲述，该节目的观众得到的不仅仅是听到的人，也就是孩子们，这真的，这太棒了。
It's really great.
真的很棒。
But isn't there, what's the thing it was in season one where I think it was Wendy the waitress put down the hot lasagna and said, don't touch that, it's really hot and Lily had to touch it?
但不是吗，在第一季中，我认为是女服务员温迪放下热烤宽面条并说，不要碰它，它真的很热，莉莉不得不碰它？
Yes, yes.
是的，是的。
Exactly.
确切地。
Everyone had to touch the hot plate of lasagna that they knew they shouldn't touch yeah, and we it's kind of a theme on the show We have there's another episode where the narrator said like, you know, basically is making the case for making mistakes You know, it's a mistake, but you have to make it anyway That's a different episode, but it's it's kind of here too.
每个人都必须触摸他们知道不应该触摸的烤宽面条的热板，是的，我们这是节目的一个主题我们还有另一集，旁白说，你知道，基本上是在为犯错误做准备你知道，这是一个错误，但你无论如何都必须犯那是另一集，但这里也是这样。
I wonder Craig.
我想知道克雷格。
Did you ever think I?
你有没有想过我？
Suspect the reason parents tell their kids stories of their own folly is the hope that they can spare them that yeah But do you think that's what narrator Ted is doing in this in this thing?
怀疑父母给孩子讲自己愚蠢的故事的原因是希望他们能够避免他们这样做，是的，但是你认为这就是叙述者特德在这件事上所做的吗？
I think he's doing that a little bit But I think also because I do this I find myself doing this with my daughter especially now where I I'll tell her story But something stupid I'm doing not cuz I think it will make her not do those things although.
我认为他做了一点但我认为也因为我这样做，我发现自己在和我的女儿做这件事，特别是现在我会告诉她的故事，但我不会做一些愚蠢的事情，因为我认为这会让她不做那些事情。
She's probably smarter than me she but because She'll feel safer to make mistakes to know that her dad made them to well in some ways Yes, it dethrones the parent from the role of God and makes them human.
她可能比我聪明，但因为她会觉得犯错误更安全，因为她知道她的父亲在某些方面让他们变得很好是的，它废除了父母的上帝角色，使他们成为人类。
Let's capture the parent mythology and say that it's all fallibility, it's all trial and error, there's no perfect, don't let anyone tell you different.
让我们抓住父母的神话，并说这都是易错的，都是反复试验的，没有完美的，不要让任何人告诉你不同的。
Yeah, your parents should be the first people telling you that.
是的，你的父母应该是第一个告诉你这些的人。
And so I think my wife Ted's also trying to do that.
所以我认为我的妻子特德也在尝试这样做。
And mistakes made courageously and not life-threateningly often lead to pretty great lives.
勇敢地犯错误而不是危及生命往往会带来美好的生活。
You know like it's how you learn you want to make some big you want to take some big swings and make some big mistakes Yeah, and when you're young Yeah, that's what your job is it's true.
你知道，这就是你学习的方式，你想要做出一些大事，你想要做出一些重大转变，犯一些大错误，是的，当你年轻的时候，是的，这就是你的工作，这是真的。
It's true.
这是真的。
I mean, it's almost like your body Rebounds quickly and so does your spirit in some ways, you know, you just and I think you become more risk averse the older you get You know not always but yeah And maybe that's a part where you want to warn people off the risk because you forget that there was something exciting about taking risks and making mistakes And the younger you had to do it.
我的意思是，这几乎就像你的身体迅速反弹，你的精神在某些方面也是如此，你知道，我认为你随着年龄的增长会变得更加厌恶风险你知道并不总是如此，但是是的也许这就是你想要警告人们远离风险的部分，因为你忘记了冒险和犯错误是令人兴奋的，而且你越年轻就必须这样做。
It was it was your job.
这是你的工作。
Yeah Well, we're thrilled by both those letters.
是的，我们对这两封信感到非常兴奋。
Thank you so much again if you want to write into us HWM YM how we made your mother calm go up to contact drop us a note.
再次非常感谢您，如果您想写信给我们 HWM YM 我们如何让您母亲平静下来，请联系我们，给我们留言。
We love to hear from you.
我们很高兴收到您的来信。
It was great to be with you this week Thanks so much.
很高兴本周能和你在一起，非常感谢。
We'll see you next time.
我们下次见。
I am guilty Please equip me All sins off again New York City How We Made Your Mother is hosted and executive produced by Josh Radner and Craig Thomas, and it's presented and distributed by the Office Ladies Network and Odyssey.
我有罪 请再次装备我 所有罪孽 纽约市 我们如何造就了你的母亲 由乔什·拉德纳和克雷格·托马斯主持并执行制作，由 Office Ladies Network 和 Odyssey 出品和发行。
The show is also executive produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey, and the show is produced and edited by me, Alec Lev.
该节目还由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛担任执行制作人，由我亚历克·列夫制作和编辑。
Our co-producer is Doug Matica.
我们的联合制片人是道格·马蒂卡。
Our audio producer and mixer is Alex Reeves, Appointed Blue Studios, and our Gen Z Masters, our digital content producer, Emily Blumberg, and associate producer, Katherine Grove.
我们的音频制作人和混音师是 Blue Studios 指定的 Alex Reeves，我们的 Z 世代大师、我们的数字内容制作人 Emily Blumberg 以及副制作人 Katherine Grove。
Artwork by John Morrow.
约翰·莫罗的艺术作品。
Please follow, rate, and review the show on Apple Podcasts or your podcast player of choice.
请在 Apple 播客或您选择的播客播放器上关注、评分和评论该节目。
It really does help to spread the word.
它确实有助于传播信息。
Our theme song is New York City by our own Josh Radner with additional music by Craig Thomas and Andrew Majuski.
我们的主题曲是我们自己的 Josh Radner 创作的《New York City》，其他音乐由 Craig Thomas 和 Andrew Majuski 创作。
Special thanks Thanks to Sam Theobold and Elliot Connors.
特别感谢 Sam Theobold 和 Elliot Connors。
Go to HowWeMajorMother.com to learn more and click on the contact page to send us an email or a voice message.
请访问 HowWeMajorMother.com 了解更多信息，然后单击联系页面向我们发送电子邮件或语音消息。
Your stories and questions are an important part of the show.
您的故事和问题是节目的重要组成部分。
Subscribe to Josh Radner's Muse Letters on Substack and check out his music and everything else at JoshRadner.com.
在 Substack 上订阅 Josh Radner 的 Muse Letters，并在 JoshRadner.com 上查看他的音乐和其他所有内容。
Order Craig Thomas' debut novel, That's Not How It Happened, Wherever Books Are Sold, And read his other published writing at CraigThomasRider.com.
订购克雷格·托马斯的处女作《事情不是这样发生的，无论书在哪里》，并在 CraigThomasRider.com 上阅读他出版的其他作品。
And you could subscribe to my own Dead Fathers Society on Substep.
你也可以在 Substep 上订阅我自己的《已故父亲协会》。
To learn about how you make a difference, this shows ongoing campaign to raise funds for congenital heart disease research, check out the Make a Difference tab at the top of our website.
要了解您如何做出改变，这显示了正在进行的为先天性心脏病研究筹集资金的活动，请查看我们网站顶部的“做出改变”选项卡。
will, in fact, dance.
事实上，会跳舞。